what
are you sure they can hear us well we
are having a sound reading now
how about now can you hear us
update in the chat now you can hear us
yeah
so we did it it allowed for a hilarious
bet that's
that's the trade-off that we get is uh
you know it goes live successfully with
no problems we don't have to do any
macgyvering
and uh you know it's just soundless for
the first 40 seconds and for the people
who have been to our live streams before
does this camera look clearer to you
yeah how are the colors
uh is there any de-lacing or ghostly
clearer right
we look better hell yeah that's what i'm
talking about we are currently
projecting in high definition 60 frames
per second
john i think it's time we shout out some
people whose names we're seeing in the
live
chelsea brown i'm seeing bro
kate luxor kobe elliott
i couldn't actually scream i had to you
know do bit screaming i like bit
screaming
meganmusic25 hello anisa of course
hey we got these discord shirts rosie
loves that new camera qual haven't been
to yeah i know
um beautiful john got a new card reader
for us to fix it yeah i got a new key
we're not going live this week until we
can fix the camera quality do you
understand me john
and i was like and then the next days
like i already got something
that's just the thing i've been meaning
to break why the [ __ ] didn't you bring
it in
earlier if it's if it's been good
hey man this is this maiden voyage this
is it's this is it's
it's first run doing doing the real deal
so
this will be it from now on it looks
like an actual video that's great to
hear
hey mark leach thank you i got some we
got this is a discord shirt
so uh yeah i thought today since
honestly john uh let's let's do a little
bit of a pre-face here hey katie ann
thanks for the t-shirt haiti
tyler hagan here too uh little preface
here
john and i are both a little out of it
um
we partied so hard have
not been quarantining at all and uh
there are bars open in la
yeah and we were like let's hit that
[ __ ] get that [ __ ] up let's do some
workshops
strangers dance with them get sweaty
so no i think the smoke in l.a has
started like i noticed i've been having
that thing of
i feel like really out of it and tired
i've been feeling that way the past few
days
and today really hit me hard and like an
idiot i went on a run i was like if i
just wear my mask
really tight the whole time but that
wasn't the smart idea
yeah there's some crazy wildfires
happening right now
oh millions of acres burnt and then
the other day i was so misled
the other day there was no sun in the
sky
and i was like oh wow it's nice to get
some not
blazing hot weather today and then i
realized
it's then my girlfriend told me and then
i was looking up
like these pictures apparently there's
no clouds in the sky because it's all
smoke
i think that's that's part of it is like
i don't know exactly how you react to
the weather but like when it's an
overcast like a rainy day i usually feel
like
a bit more peaceful but also kind of
coast right and then
you have this where it's like it's a
pseudo rainy day where it
it kind of is it's got that soft
lighting but everything is really orange
instead of blue
and it's like you can't breathe you just
know the air sucks and so i think it's
that it's like
your body is like looking outside going
i should be cozy
and yet my lungs just feel bad yeah man
and today walking around was like oh
it's it's starting to have that blade
runner 2049 look again
where everything's really red everywhere
it's really smoky
which which leads me to one of my i just
want to throw this in now one of my
favorite movie tropes
is uh because it's applicable right now
and it's not a favorite because it's a
good thing but uh whenever someone's
like
that's not snow it's ash
that that always gets me uh that's a
great john
john the master of segways over here
look at john cena
so uh yeah i don't know what the
actually one of the major fires
someone's
uh otaku in the chat's asking one of the
major fires
is um is oh yeah hit the like button on
the stream thanks for minding me katie
uh one of the one one of the fires was
started by a gender
reveal party this is confirmed not some
silly rumor
and they're looking at an eight million
dollar lawsuit i thought you were going
to say this is confirmed not not some
silly function
like i thought you were about to like
hyper legitimize someone had a gender
reveal party oh my god over a gender
reveal partner and it's like that of all
parties the gender reveal party
and am i am i remembering poorly or is
this not the first time this has
happened with a gender reveal party
i don't know i feel like a different i
mean definitely not this bad
no um so it was a gender reveal party
fire went off this couple or are looking
at an eight million dollar lawsuit right
now
and it's just like wow yeah as much as
like you're responsible for burning a
lot of people's homes down and
endangering a lot of people's lives
it's like terrible time to have a baby
am i right
well and why do you need that many
fireworks
to reveal which set of genitals your kid
got i know is that [ __ ]
like i don't understand why that level
of celebration
because if like if it's the reveal like
what if uh
you know you don't get the one you want
do you still like the fireworks
i don't know i bet that guy's like do we
really want this baby
i saw a good meme about it though it
said uh it's not a gender reveal party
it's just a genital reveal party jesus
christ
it was pretty good but yeah like oh god
it's like you guys aren't this is
literally why we can't have nice things
um well let's go into the stream the
actual topic of the stream today now
that we've been here for seven minutes
and 40 seconds
explaining the smoke and the fires in la
it's silent hill
hello mirna in the chat i think we did
say hi to you and then erica tuesday has
joined us sylvester i always love seeing
the familiar faces
it feels like a group hangout here
that's what i think what makes our live
streams unique i feel like ours feel
like a group hangout yeah
don't they they do because like even i
don't know even though it's hard to keep
up with the chat like every time we
bounce back in it just feels like we're
in a big room full of people somehow
look at all these other channels with
less subs than us who get like hundreds
more or like
hundreds to a thousands more people
watching usually during their live
streams
that's why i looked at john earlier this
week and said we need better quality
live streams shot that's good well and
your live streams are so fun and funny
and i'm like but no one's watching i
think the quality of the camera has
something to do with the job
maybe and maybe part of the charm of the
streams is yeah that
it's like we got to take the time to get
to your input
whether it be in the super chats the uh
stream labs or just in the chat
chat and also guys check this bad boy
out
because uh it gets blazing hot in here
this is a mini air conditioner right
here
mini air conditioner we actually have
and the boys reactions going tomorrow
i was worried that the mic was picking
up the whole time it's so
quiet it is you can't even hear the fan
in the boys video tomorrow dude it's so
quiet and it really has been helping
a lot with keeping uh keeping this cool
right now and you just fill water in the
top and
and off you go all right john we should
probably go into the actual topic
today to the topic it's okay oh [ __ ]
what's up living tombstones in the chat
everybody go
check out the living tombstone just go
look them up on you leave this stream
around
just go there later i'll expect everyone
to just go there
point in time tonight go check out
new album zero one and just like any and
all things on the channel because like i
can't explain the history right now
you can do that better but he's making
some killer tunes so go listen
it's cool cool stuff fair enough fair
enough i got a trope here
i got a trope a dope trope a trope that
i do not like oh and bradley i see you
super chatted thank you so much for the
tip
buddy um there was uh uh i will get to
your your super chat in just a minute
but here's a trope that has risen
within the boys themselves and uh it's
something
that is always seems too predictable
it's when someone's having a phone call
they're having a phone call and you're
and as an audience
like you probably shouldn't be having
this phone call right now because
someone is likely to overhear you who's
probably an integral character who might
say some [ __ ]
who might get you in trouble or who
might be surveilling you're just
watching the show going
or the movie just get off the phone
don't talk on the phone right now and
don't talk so loud too
you know dude yeah and boom
sure enough they and it's always when
they hang up the phone it's just
oh right one oh [ __ ] this person's
watching me
yeah they always have that like moment
of like jumping like it's a horror movie
they're like
well i'm just being normal what are you
what are you up to it's like
who are these friends in all these
movies when someone's on the phone
they're just like
who the [ __ ] you talking to man you know
what i want to do
is i want to make like a thriller but
all comprised of the [ __ ] that we have
cut away from that makes it scary
like you're just watching the person
like crouch and listen for a long time
and then like position themselves and
like find a new position and figure out
how to you know
attack uh yeah i agree with i agree with
this assessment john humphrey and and
piggybacking off of that i mean just
yeah like earshot in
in general because there are so many
things in in movies and
shows where people are yeah either on
the phone or like having
conversations like right here in front
of other characters
uh and it's just it's it there's such a
thing as earshot and i feel like there
are so many movies that hinge on like
how clandestine and how
uh you know adept their characters are
at being stealthy
and then that always takes me out when
they're like you know having a chat
in the wrong place i i like that one
here's another chat and i see some of
you guys have contributed to our stream
labs and super chats thank you we're
going to get to those in just one minute
um uh and no i haven't been to chile
someone on the chat keeps asking me
so um here's another trip i hate
when during the times of kovid they keep
announcing movies that are going to come
out
and they just keep delaying them
terrible tropes it's an
industry trope guys at this point you
can release dates
first i'm sick of this [ __ ] i love
no this is this is literally what's
making quarantine fun because i like
they did it
with tennis they printed billboards
multiple times for multiple dates that
did not
land yes and they spent money on that oh
joseph in the chat has one that i uh i
am i
i don't i am sick of oh uh joseph
said it he said casually walking away
from explosions
it's been done so it's been done to
death it's the most
action hero trope or bad guy trope in
the world
but you know if if i made an ex i mean
how often does do these
people see an explosion of that caliber
to the point where they're like i don't
even want to look at it right now
see that's the thing i don't even want
to check this [ __ ] out like why would
you not want to look
just take a glance over your shoulder
and be like [ __ ] that's crazy
like literally if you want these things
to be more realistic that's the point
the characters would be at by the fifth
installment
like by by whatever die hard five then
he should be walking away unfazed
because now we've
seen him grow accustomed and how often
do these people walk away from
explosions
because they seem like they're trained
to not feel the
impact of an explode because if an
explosion goes off you know where you're
going to be like you're going to be like
you're going to be blessed there's going
to be like an end
of like a pressure blast and not only
that but you might like have some
trouble with your eardrums if you're too
close like it makes no sense yeah that's
what i mean
like it might blow your ears down it
could be debris that gets on the back of
your neck
yeah exactly there's a lot and no one
ever [ __ ] look like you do
how cool the i can i can understand it
if if it's something like man on fire
with denzel
like you [ __ ] are gonna pray
and you're just walking away like that
emotional pull
but it happens way too often to the
point where i'm like just take a look
you got it why wouldn't you want to see
an explosion see your handiwork yeah
you want to be sure of what you've done
yeah man what's up biff tannen you're
pretty sexy especially in part two when
you're in the thong
um i've been hearing about this movie
some uh shawnzee uh in the chat's
bringing up this movie called cuties
i've been hearing a lot about it
and uh i i don't know any details so i'm
thinking we should do a reaction to it
we should do a watch along for cuties
and see whether or not it is the the
pedophilia manifesto
is that what it's about we're not
watching that then you know it's about
uh a few young girls who join a twerking
dance crew according to netflix in the
that was the literal wording they used
the first show we should then uh
i think before they changed it you know
what other industry trope i'm getting
sick of
canceling movies cancelling movies yeah
i think we should cancel little miss
sunshine for what they did with
abigail breslin at the end of that movie
yeah you could argue that that's kind of
i i feel like you can
i feel like you know there's there's got
to be i i'm
uncomfortable in that scene yeah i mean
i do too actually
like i hope everybody on the set was
cool it's funny and awkward but you're
like oh this is kind of an icky thing
i hope no one in the crowd is enjoying
this but
um i want to start a fake like cancel
one but of course treat it like it's
real yeah
to see if i could just do it like how
easy could it be to cancel
cancel a movie i feel a little miss
sunshine which hasn't been targeted i
think
you can easily cancel little miss
sunshine
cancel a little miss sunshine i love
that i want it i love this movie and i
want to do it just to see if i can like
get it going
it's already happening
okay hey all right you know we got some
super chats um
but uh oh yeah maddie in the stream you
guys have been putting so many great
tropes in the stream every hacker every
hacker every movie
oh my god the one hacker which has one
of john's uh
john wrote down one that i really like
it's about the keyboards
oh which one where is that about about
when people and
like i won't do it so i don't [ __ ] up
the stream when people
like over type yeah when people over
type in movies and shows where it just
doesn't
like i can always tell when someone's
not doing it for real
yeah i mean the the best example i can
give you of a
of an actor who's doing keyboard typing
and you're like there's there's no way
he is he's typing way more than what
he's saying and like really
hard he includes this actor who never
learned to type yeah yeah yeah
who's uh uh who's the dad and pirates of
the caribbean to
um karen knightley jonathan price price
not the president from game of thrones
um
uh jonathan price and tomorrow never
dies he has this scene
where he is he's writing up a fake
article fake news and he's just typing
like
obnoxiously yeah you're typing way
faster than the words that are coming
out on the page right now
weirdly weirdly the most recent example
i can think of is when we were watching
i said hi to you and you so we did
anissa we were watching at astra
and it was in the same moment that
natasha leone showed up and i was like
oh cool natasha leon
my hand my eyes immediately went to her
hands because like the typing was like
this looks like a piece of b-roll where
she wasn't even like
thinking she was supposed to be typing
because of how silly the motion looked
so uh and it same thing goes with
instruments like it's a little harder
because not everybody uses that as much
as a keyboard but like
i can always tell when they're playing
and they don't have even the slightest
idea of where these notes might be
it's like i can i can forgive enough if
you at least try to be in a position or
if you know it's a chord versus you know
like some kind of lead line
solo thing but like yeah when people are
playing and it's just clear that
there's been no acquaintance to the
instrument at all it's just i can't
click it i agree with this johnny um
and here's uh here's i'm gonna before we
go into some of these tropes so that you
guys have submitted our super
chats and stuff um there's one trope i
actually do
like that is very overused but
you do it the right way with the right
level of stakes
and the right follow-up action hero
punch line okay i can get on board with
this trope
it is he's he's down to one bullet
down to one bullet trophy you know and i
think mission impossible three does a
great job with that
where uh him and carrie russell are in
the shootout they're trying to get out
and then she's like how much you how
many rounds you got left and he looks at
his clip but you don't know how much
he's got left
and he just looks at her he doesn't even
look and he's like enough
enough that's all he says enough and
then in slow motion he turns
and then the last bad guy who has like
infinite amounts of [ __ ] ammo
he goes and one shot in the head falls
through the glass
and he goes now i'm empty
make it a thing yeah that was uh that
was a badass moment in mission
impossible three but
okay some of you guys are coming in here
right now we'd be dicks to not get
some of them at this point our penises
all right
i really do appreciate all the tips in
the super chats and stream labs as well
just the tip pull it up john we're gonna
have your
super chats displaying proudly on screen
proudly higher quality resolution in our
videos thanks to john
hey thanks to john any old day of the
week
i give credit when credit is due but
more importantly i give credit to myself
as much as i can oh dude you deserve
publicly
more than anyone else i'm the last
person to empower another don't
don't have me presented an award to
power myself
by the end you'll be confused as to who
won i would always talk about how great
my presentation was
over the person who actually won that's
just the way i
roll wow we got a pretty good all right
thank you guys we are already behind
awesome that's our style alrighty let's
start let's get these
first ones who's the first one i think
the first one was bradley right yeah
bradley thank you buddy bradley who made
our new banner
hey made our new banner thank you brad
thank you so much bradley should be on
the shirt right somewhere here
yeah right here bradley yes this is a
shirt this special shirt here
is something that um our discordo jacks
have made
yeah and uh love the hell out of you
guys
so what did bradley say bradley
john can we can we punch a tad tighter
even
though it's okay it's okay don't fret
don't fret
you messed it up oh no okay i did good
with getting the the capture card to
improve the quality of our live streams
john but
you know let's honor their names here
you know just uh
that was actually hard to get because
now like people uh
scalp the prices so high and they are in
such high demand that like
they're backed up on shipping for months
on end so like i actually
managed to like laser in and get a good
deal on this
hell yeah so thanks ebay all right
bradley bledsoe go check out his channel
sketchy studios
and his music as well bradley loves star
hell yeah i'm sorry
he said no no don't be sorry i'm sorry
shouting him out sorry bradley
probably says hey dudes one of my least
favorite tropes is
this is my crime scene now with a rich
guy holding an envelope
lol stay safe guys wait a minute i got
to slow down on this trope all right we
should probably highlight so people know
where we are
um wait a minute okay so
you're this is my crime scene now with a
rich guy holding an envelope is he
implying that
the guy who's steps in like if it's a
cop like a detective and then [ __ ]
fbi why are the fbi like always dicks
everyone hates
the fbi is never the hero they work for
the
if you're a detective i'm i'm i'm
thinking to myself like oh [ __ ]
fbi's here yeah they're much more
equipped to handle this crime than we're
like
us times 10. it's like how selfish
how selfish of a [ __ ] of a detective
do you have to be
like oh i would have sold this i'm like
well this person's
crime because it's all faster with the
fbi man um
see this is one of those tropes that
pushes your your like hero anti-hero
cop like to go right you know okay so
bradley just clarified it in the stream
okay he bought he's bought the rights to
be on the crime scene
is what's implied so i'm not as familiar
with that aspect of it i'm more familiar
with the trope i was saying yeah
of fbi shows up over detective scene fbi
somebody
takes the scene now usually to go in
hand with your trouble i'm not really so
familiar with the holding an envelope
part
but usually the fbi guy is corrupt and
that's what makes the fbi
guy a bad dude or he just has worst
policies in the world that blinds into
the truth all the time and that's how we
focus on the detectives but thank you
buddy
appreciate it heck yeah we also got
tariq
allen oh did we yes we did sorry there's
a speaker
over here oh snap totally skipped over
you terry yeah
i did not mean to do that i love your
name thank you for the tip
we're doing this like tennis i assume in
multiple
directions of time maybe no spoilers
guys i found out tenet
is playing at a couple of theaters only
about
50 miles away i'm gonna make the
and here's the thing i was gonna try to
go tonight to watch tenet
um as i was like because when you go to
the tickets it's all social distance
spaced out the way they've designed
their theaters
and i haven't been to a theater since
covet right and um
tennant is playing 50 miles away right
now and uh but i was like okay if i'm
gonna drive like about a hundred miles
i'm gonna want to make sure i got great
seats right now there's no good seats
available
so i'm looking into tickets for next
weekend because i want to make sure we
can still cover the boys
and give our editors some time to cut
that up and so i'm gonna try to go next
weekend
uh and yeah but i got so excited because
i was like
the nearest theater so i don't want to
see tenant out of driving all right i'm
not gonna do that that's fair
i don't wanna do that especially for
tenet because
he's designed that movie to be for the
big screen on imax i just don't want to
see it in a car
all right um but then uh uh
where would i want to see tennant going
all right let's go on to the super chat
tariq thank you dude he says hi guys i'm
ready i'm getting ready to write a
script
what genre would you like for me to
write it's okay to choose three
okay i'd like you to write a how do we
do one
one at a time and then we'll say the
third one together okay okay
i think the first genre you got to do is
um coming of age oh damn that's what i
was going to say
the second one john get it going uh uh
okay
so coming of age but then you also have
to do it as a man versus nature kind of
movie
like the gray or like the edge yes i
like that and then on top of that
um i i want it to be also gonna be it's
a
uh it's a it's a coming-of-age werewolf
versus the elements movie
all right dude because i want you to
pull off a movie where people are like
that sounds convoluted
but then you do it because that proves
the kind of level of screenwriter you
are this better be a mini series
by the way it's the only way it's gonna
be able to flow oh yeah cause think of
the level of conflict you could have
like man versus the elements and then
werewolf versus the elements it's two
different sets man
very true very very true sequels dominic
zeferi um thank you dominic appreciate
the tip buddy
thank you a dominic such a great name
dominant i've never met a bad looking
guy or seen a bad looking guy named
dominic
let's find one let's find one dominic
pull up your profile pic
let's judge uh he says no hate this
trope
we're not so different you and i
said by villains in movies yeah that's a
that's a thing
i mean that's what makes a great villain
though yeah marvel
it was amazing yeah [ __ ] marvel star
trek
that's what makes a great villain is uh
a lot of times
when there's that duality of like i've
been watching a little anime
show called naruto ooh
um so naruto and then he just met uh
he just had this whole like arc with
this character named gara
and i'm sure that the five people who
actually watched naruto in the stream
are really appreciating this right now
naruto fans are out but a big difference
of them is like with just a slight bit
of difference in the way
their past experiences played out they
could have ended up on the same path
the hero could have ended up the villain
the villain might have been a hero
oh man but that we're not so different
you and i is a line that is
definitely overused so thank you dominic
you don't need to tell us that anymore
we're not so because that implies the
evilness the evil nature of them
uh even more so i think and i feel like
there's actually more weight when
there's just more
showing less telling in uh the word
and as opposed to saying we're not so
different you and i
aren't i deep you are dude i'm so so
dude hashtag that [ __ ] greg's so deep
hashtag
deep hashtag dude if jesus can walk on
water
can he swim on land oh
in these trying times i missed the bo
burnham me too
i missed the bo burnham anissa oliva
one of our queens annie plex hey guys i
got great news for you she was worried
she
coveted
movie that bothers oh no john you read
it she loves you the more than me
the horror movie that bothers me 24
7 lol is when someone falls ha ha
someone always has to fall and they
possibly end up dying so yeah
i love y'all hearts oh that's true
especially in horror they always fall
you know what's worse than horror like
both usually a horror movie if they have
this element of
of someone falling you know unless it's
like a real
situation where you could easily trip if
it's in case no
hurry it's a case like right but there's
enough lazy uses
exactly yeah yeah um but usually the
the movies that also possess this
quality also have this trope that i hate
because usually they fall in like the
street or something you know
where it's like flat yeah it's like it's
not you would have to just be tripping
over your feet at that point
when they go in to start their vehicle
and then it's
not starting up i hate that trope too
you know what i just watched scream for
last night and they did it
and i was so flipping glad that when
ghostface jumps on the hood of that one
scene
he's got like a piece of car wire [ __ ]
in his hand so i was like oh cool
explanation for that yeah it's not just
the gods telling you the car doesn't
work there's a way to set it
up you know because like how maddie is
pointing out in the chat
bruh why in every horror movie they be
in the woods alone what the [ __ ]
and usually when a character falls you
know if it's in the woods
as as much as that has become a trope in
it of itself like they fall in the woods
right
when they're trying to get away um which
is why when you're running in the woods
you know look on the ground yeah yeah
but if it's nighttime i get when they
fall oh totally right it's not
it's night it's just one if you're on a
a a rat
yeah a rat a rock movie they keep
tripping on [ __ ] rats man
well and the thing is it's weird if
you're you're running
upward i believe it less if you're
running downward it's harder to run
down in like rocky or foresty terrain if
you don't
understand where your feet are gonna go
exactly so you know what's one that's
that's
that really i will never laugh at
another horror movie
keys are hard as [ __ ] to work when
you're like rattled
he's like trying to find a key and like
get it in a thing if you're actually
kind of like freaked out is is not easy
yeah it's true john
so that's a good call i'll give it to
you thank you anisa see sometimes when
you guys submit a trope
it reminds us of another dope trope it's
like a cat
i used to live near a street called
verdugo
and there's near silver lake
i made you thank you verdugo for the tip
his
his trope that his dope trope that he
doesn't like is
oh i can't do that you can't
or you won't uh i just saw that in
something
scream four if it's all probably every
they probably had like a master list of
like did we get all the tropes are we
met
enough yeah oh goodness
i think i think it what's funny about
this trope junkie highlight that for me
always
when someone says i can't do that you
can't or you won't i actually think
that's a great personal life philosophy
to apply to yourself
yeah or to challenge someone on it you
can't or you won't because nine times
out of ten
it's not that you can't it's just that
you won't should could
would or maybe you aren't
right um but yes i can't do that you
can't even
is an overused line and funny enough
as much as i think that's a great
personal life philosophy to ask yourself
once in a while
because hashtag greg is so deep greg's
so dupe
craig so do you is uh that is an
overused line
yeah that really is we actually did one
of our very early videos that we ever
did
one of the very early 101 most overused
movie lines
yeah we should have just pulled that
video up and played it for the industry
we should have just played it here but
like there you go 101 overused lines in
movies
yeah like turn in your badge and your
weapon
oh oh i love it i'm sure a cop has heard
that before oh sure
well it's weird when they say it's
someone who's not a cop
but which one i i like it too when uh
this has become a very big trope in
terms of just like lines of like
his methods are pregnant pause
unorthodoxy
[Music]
like that's that's that like i've heard
that so many times now and it always
means the the same thing
yeah good call john goody goody
all right jay tevo hey buddy thanks for
the tip buddy i think this is the first
time seeing your name in our chat unless
you're someone who's been here before
and you've changed
your name either way i appreciate it
dude john
read away his dope trope the trope
where on the phone someone gets attacked
then cause the call just stops
do they just take time to hang up surely
we just hear the altercation
that is a great call yeah that's i don't
even know especially in the age of cell
phones
yeah like phones get dropped and just
like everyone
if you it always makes me think of that
episode the simpsons the the parody the
shining where
marge like radios and she's like my
husband's gone crazy and it's attacking
everyone over
and then it comes back to chief wagon
and he's just like oh i'm glad that's
over
that's so true the cops would have so
much more evidence too
yeah if the call just played on
because i feel like an on a actually no
on any phone it should still keep going
right unless they drop it and it breaks
yes and one thing i learned from
listening to an old spill.com review is
apparently phones can always if you can
connect
at all to 3g even if you you don't have
a sim or whatever you can always dial
9-1-1
you guys don't see this but sometimes
i'm like john's talking
he's looking at this white box i have
the habit too i'll be looking at the
because we could see our the playback of
the video it's the playback of the video
we're looking here talking to
me watching the playback then i'm like
oh wait you guys are right here
not right here it's it's that skype call
problem that we can often
have we know i don't remember what i was
saying
so sometimes you see my hand extending
so you can't see me doing it but i'm
doing
look up john and i have to i am
totally guilty of that too um but thank
you
that's a thinker right there thank you
for that man yeah a lot of times with
these dope tropes
which are not really dope hashtag
correct so deep
is that is that um
a lot of these tropes can often present
themselves with these logical
uh errors like when we're not asking
yourself like would the character do
that or would that thing actually happen
yeah and um because sometimes things are
just so reoccurring
it's like all right i'm sick of this
because we got a few of our own two that
more that we got we're gonna list off
but yeah
this is a logical one and i like when
people point out like the real
logical gaps in a lot of these tropes
but anissa since
john red your last one thank you anisa
um she's asking us personally
who of y'all too is the good cop and the
bad cop
um but that that does play on the trope
though
of like once good cop one's back see
we're like three cops in that greg is
good cop and bag cop and i'm just good
cop
john is uh the guy behind the counter
and the guy is
i've never been to a police station i've
been to a couple
like on-campus police stations and maybe
one actual police station i've never
seen one that had like a podium with
like a guy and a badge and a hat be like
i am the official police welcomer yeah
what is your problem
that's a trope that needs to exist in
real life but
the good cop back the good cop bad cop
routine
meta meta metal
gear letter geraldo 50 million dollars
yeah pickle rick
fandom john is definitely but to answer
your question
john is definitely good cop i'm bad cop
i have my methods are unorthodox
every day every time like a video won't
upload fast enough he just throws a pot
of hot coffee at the computer screen and
i go you son of a [ __ ] tell me why
you're not processing
obviously he's got a lamp above that he
can just throw right in the webcam's
face
come on tell me what i want i want that
truth and john's always like
back off man he's a witness
come just calm down he's gone you're one
week without your pension
looking out for you oh eric horstmann
thank you eric horseman
e h my man love you dude hell's yes
over used horror trope the slow pulling
down of
blankets in many ways too because like
sometimes there's the slow pulling down
from the foot of the bed
sometimes there's the slow pulling down
when you know the ghost is like
on your crotch because that's where they
would have to be
because if they're any further down you
probably just not see them
you see in movies
i think that's become i think the grudge
was the first one to really
popularize that where they opened the
blanket yeah
and then there's the [ __ ] ghost scary
juwon girl
is right there oh my gosh it's just like
that's that's terrifying that is a
terrifying thing
the the issue i have with it that more
movies do this now
is it's the logical gap there
of if i feel like something's on me if i
feel like a bug is on me yeah yeah i
feel like there's a
bug on me i'm like what the [ __ ]
literally
literally like a hair a stray hair can
fall onto my exposed leg and i'll be
like is this tarantula
have you ever walked and thought you
walked through a spider web and you're
like jesus christ there's a black widow
on me
especially in the summer time um if i if
i
if if i feel there is a sentient being
the size of a of a child on my lap
under the blanket yeah i'm not gonna go
what
if if i feel this weight
thing on me see me because it is
physical
but maybe that's the thing maybe that's
super spooky ghost magic where they can
just feel like a satin sheet for a while
until they want you to understand
that their mass exists it's [ __ ]
what's up jenna randolph
mr fajou mr vajoo are you
is this a true story were you once
attacked in a parking lot while on the
phone and you dropped your phone on the
floor and
your friend heard you say no don't kill
me so he called the cops for you and
spoiler alert you survived
and then he got on this livestream his
live streams
like i got us i gotta give him a super
chat to the real
[ __ ] and i got proof
we're glad you're you're good you're
okay damn that's a terrifying story that
is a terrifying story whenever i've
witnessed a crime from afar i just get
in the car and
drive off for some reason
as far as i can go i witnessed a crime
from 50 yards nine times out of ten i
pack my bags like i don't want the cops
knocking on my door
well mr vajrayo i'm glad you're safe
seriously you actually we have we're on
your super chat
hey good timing on that dude you want to
take this one uh
no you take it take it take it do you
take it good cop
go take a good card i hate when villains
waste time explaining their plan to the
good guys giving them a chance to escape
or
stall for no reason or figure out like
the critical element to solve
the you know villainy yeah that's true
it can also be
terrible like because you're talking
about giving them time to escape it can
also be terrible especially when they're
like
not cuffed but have rope around their
hands and
and them explaining their plan is
is like uh you know they're like they
happen to have like some knife on them
they like cut it open or something
i've done that i'm starting to that's
one that i wanted mythbusters on can you
really like get a piece of like glass
and like etch your way out of
yeah as much as action heroes always do
i'm not a big fan generally of villain
on
like unveiling their whole plan to the
main character
not unless it's an ideological conflict
yeah it makes sense for them to butt
heads about like to hanos
yeah like tahinos or komenger
or anyone who has some condition about
there's overpopulation and he's gonna
save the environment
to any villain like that's a trope
that's a villain trope for the last
few years even godzilla king of the
monsters humans are the
mother nature wants to reset from the
humans
humans have ruined the world so unleash
these monsters to destroy everything
i'm gonna aid this process that i see by
you know making a lot of money and
releasing hell on earth
humans have ruined us so unleash these
nukes
let's ruin it indefinitely release these
nukes damn it
oh sarah campbell thank you so much
sarah my dear cindy campbell driving in
an apocalypse and you see people
flagging you down for help
even though you shouldn't you stop and
they carjack you just keep driving
dude that is stupid because you know why
whenever a character picks up a
hitchhiker
it's just a stupid idea yeah so
it's like that's so don't pick up the
hitchhiker don't pick up a normal
hitchhiker yeah
it's like i have a little sympathy in
the apocalypse but also
still yeah i feel you i have gotten out
of my car in real life if i see someone
on the street who's like trying to push
their car or whatever
i've done that a few times yeah or
someone who needs uh a jump uh
i mean who's like hiding a body and just
trying to get the last bit in
yeah or shoot the tires out of my
vehicle yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] now i'm
being held hostage
and then uh i gotta mr baju's story
this is glad you're saying that's a
terrifying story yeah seriously
but yeah that's a good call sarah don't
ever pick up the hitchhiker or don't
help people on the side of the road
you got to be like all californians
avoid
don't make it avoid avoiding i just
don't
hear you every other state i've been to
is like hey
how you doing enjoying this hiking trail
you betcha top of the morning to you
but out here in california no we just
avoid the [ __ ] out of you hey how you
doing what do you want
what do you want from me what are you
what are you gangster what are you
you're trying to rob me or you're gonna
fight
very anti-social [ __ ] out here
in california
but also very zen and vegan um went a
little too far here mark
bleach thank you mark leach whose name
is on the discord shirt
as well thank you mark leech community
was great at piss taking tropes please
watch
one was good cop bad cop and the moment
they are off the case then it's the
moment they choose to work together to
solve it
i love you guys you've seen community
haven't you you can talk about it i've
seen a fair amount of community in fact
i think i've
seen the i've i've seen i think
specific episodes that you might be
referring to here and yeah i mean the
community does an awesome job
at being meta but also being funny and
heartfelt and doing that thing where it
wins you over by being a really
effective situation comedy but also
smartly deconstructing whatever topic at
hand
there's a great quarantine episode uh
there's a great episode where there's an
outbreak of a costume party
no you can't get cool you don't want to
get too close the idea is to [ __ ] with
the lens john oh that's it i see
you wanna
john will never shave his beard or cut
his hair or shower
three in fact i got some really great
soaps i've been trying to buy more
clearly didn't mean that john you get so
defensive
listen let me tell you about my new
soaps i showered so much
uh that's what the kids at improv that
was their go-to joke because john smells
like fish so so raw kid
i got a chip on my shoulder are we
brothers if we were brothers
wow wow one of us lucked out on the
jeans
which question to you is which one is it
which one got the good ones
don't answer that i already know what
everyone's going to say my god
insecurities self-deprecating humor
becoming reality
silver oh
do you want to take this one you want to
take this one away um
let's see here people being chased by
slasher movie villains trip and fall
more times than the rest of humanity
combined
also their cars never start and that's
the truth i'm pretty sure we
we just covered exactly that thank you
verdugo this is why we can't rift john
this is why yeah
this came in this is where we
all right all right all right let's
let's let's reconfigure ourselves with
riffing
that sounds like a book waiting to
happen like a like a
you know pamphlet for improv students
did you really get some new soaps i did
oh sweet i did i was like tell the
viewers yeah these soaps john i was like
how could i
reorganize like you know the the normal
life stuff that i spend money on in a
way that's more helpful to
uh the world right so i was like oh what
are some
i don't wanna i don't i don't wanna
aggrandize myself for shopping
we got some we got some stream lab
contributions to get to
but let's go back to the chat here for a
second and see what y'all are saying
his yum just any time to reference the
phantom with billy zane is a good time
to reference the phantom with billy zane
jenna's saying when people hide near the
killer like that one geico commercial
you know what bothers me more jenna is
the hiding under the bed trope
because they're always caught that's a
bad but
aren't they they're always caught they
are and it's always
the same [ __ ] fake out like every
time
it's like they they you think they get
away a person goes
yeah oh but and then suddenly they
they get them from behind they come out
of their ankles they come out of just
the
the negative space off camera
every single time man it's the same
trope yeah
hide under the bed is not a great one
don't but then again sometimes you just
have no ride
yeah i mean it's like hiding in the
closet
by a murderer so yeah it's like the
closet sucks just as much as the bat i
mean the closet you're arguably more
cornered in but less exposed the window
is still the best let me show you guys
where to hide if someone's coming into
your room
i'm going to show you guys exactly where
to hide
this is making me think of that yeah
just
position yourselves behind a door each
everyone in your home
every door that opens i just i just
broke the post you just destroyed the
set
but see it's not green screen that's a
practical set all right
this is this is production value vin
diesel is immortal trope
that is a that is a well it's in his
contract you know he can't appear weak
he can't take more than three
consecutive hits or something like that
anyway that's how you hide
that's me olivia said we're loud it's
only gonna get louder
it might get loud it's a good
documentary you should check it out
uh lorenzo's saying in a superhero movie
when someone is about to die
they're saved just in the nick of time
that annoys me to no end
it's kind of like that in every movie
with a hero yeah every action
any action genre that's usually what it
is they can they can handle any fall
from any any height any height again
and john wick should be dead
that stretches the the high fall trope
to a whole other level of that movie
when he f like at the end of part three
john wick at least has a concussion yeah
i wouldn't be at least needs to recover
a little bit i wouldn't be surprised if
we watched
john wick four and then they do the
trope reveal
of oh he's just in the hospital
yes yes i i want that and then he wakes
up from the coma only to find that he's
in the hospital
and a bunch of the other people he's
fought are also in the hospital so they
have like
a john wick action movie but everyone's
like really incapacitated so everyone's
like fighting
all hobbly and gross like
oh yeah uh axel in the chat is saying
when heroes don't kill the villain and
gets surprised when the villain tries to
kill them when their back is turned
it's vice versa really when you when
when someone's monologuing they take
way too long to just commit the action
of killing someone
because they wanna they wanna have them
go let off a speech
and then that's you get to the point
like just hurry up and do it before the
person [ __ ] gets you
you know that uh when when characters it
happens a lot in horror movies when like
you've incapacitated your your villain
and then you just discard whatever
weapon you had on yeah as if you'll
never
need it again uh very true
very true john wick versus kill bill
let's do it i like it that's a good
trope
um all right uh you know what trope i'm
also not a big fan of
when characters go on talk shows and
then they kill the talk show host dude
that happens way too much
often so many so many movies think of
off the top of my head
or oh he was really dead the whole time
it
became a trope or gwyneth paltrow's head
in the box yeah
or darth vader being luke's dad yeah i'm
just sick of those tropes
geez we got some stream laps too that a
lot of you guys have uh contributed to
doobity do okay let's see we are on
12 with flev doran let's
mr q that is my quote for the year john
wick should be dead
really should be really should be
running that's that's
hashtag john wick should be dead who is
our first one for today
johnny lev doran i'm trying to get this
to like a good scroll point but i'm
having trouble
hi guys hi flev hi phleb thank you so
much flabby
one trope that levy don't like flavor
one trope that i don't like when people
in horror films or in general hear a
weird sound from the basement or
whatever
and they foolishly go into the set place
always send olivia investigate always
send olivia
instead of running away or calling every
time we hear a noise
i just sent my woman mm-hmm or one of
the cats
like who's gonna carry on the alban
go out there distribute myself you have
an older brother
[Laughter]
you're already accounted for i am the
last of my bloodlines go
i'll hide in the bathroom we're under
the bed what about the other siblings
you have
they're not here right now um sorry
yeah and they foolishly go into the
space run away call
his his comment continues also in
non-rflix a man and woman have sex and
then they save the pillow talk after
the woman always has to awkwardly hold
the sheet over her chest oh yeah
talk like can you just shoot it from
another angle instead of this weird way
just show your tits lady
just show your boobs would you god
we've all seen boobs um it's perfectly
natural
you know that's when people are
breastfeeding to go off of that uh to go
off of that one flev
uh let me let me add on to to a trope in
the pg-13 pg department and sometimes
even r-rated movies do that soon i'm
like why are you doing this you're
already
is when after they have sex these uh
whatever character especially like the
first time they bone or they've been
banging for a while
yeah and then they they get up from
under the sheets
and then they they stand and they're
wearing underwear and i'm like
what do people do like oh we're done
let me just put my underwear back on and
i'm gonna cuddle with you afterwards
you know every movie and jokes they
always put their underwear back you mean
you don't fully
you don't you don't clothe yourself back
up before letting your body touch
air you don't shield your privates
you might as well put all your clothes
back on yeah
wow that's what i do if it's if you're
all sweaty and hot the hottest spot is
probably the
hilarious yeah the part that's been
doing all the friction you wouldn't just
put your underwear back on would you
there's a lot of unnatural behavior in
your beds in movies
bradley you've been married for way too
many years all right
saying in the chat is that not what
you're supposed to do i'm confused your
wife
does not ever want to get naked i'm
sorry
she's been with you for way too long
oh damn we're gonna prove a way wrong on
here
well but but you put it on under the
covers before like standing back up or
do you like
you know i feel like most people will
put it back on you know like
what they usually do with the women too
is like they they get off the
they're on the edge of the bed they're
back yeah they hold the sheet of their
back is to the camera
which is understandable it's
understandable now i feel like we gotta
like really back pedal here
i mean we've been doing post-sex wrong
all these years
well that's the thing is there it is
like
a wee bit unnatural because it just
suggests to me that both of these people
don't want each other to see to to like
they don't want to be naked around each
other
right which is like a little odd after
after a sexual encounter i guess
everyone does it
you put your underwear back on under the
covers before getting out
okay we're weird we're weird that's not
a big
deal it's not a big deal i mean do it
what you want whatever it makes you feel
sexy
like i just never i've never heard of
that i yeah
wow we were way off i figured if i was
in bed without
pantaloons they would either be on the
floor they're way outnumbered
yeah we got a back pedal now i i fully
am closed
here in fact i put on more clothes to go
to bed
we're gonna get cancelled for this i
wear these clothes to bed plus like
another pair of sweatpants on top and a
parka
maria why are you saying no point in
listening never acknowledge
well yeah i just proved you wrong yes
have a talk with your with the misses
to find out like [ __ ] and we should make
that the topic of next week's live
stream
man calling up everyone all right we're
we're very much alone here
i'm a never nude well harry
rally you you won this you won bradley
you win
you won this round bradley you won you
clearly have the whole team and
now we're getting canceled for this
hashtag greg and john's so naked
i'm usually naked that's the thing
usually like nine times out of ten
yeah it's a [ __ ] having to paint
clothes
after effects just tracking your body
put some clothes on
yeah we can't do that live so he's
actually wearing them now
um eric was here eric horstmann
best wishes everything clears up in cali
soon bad horror trip number one
i'll be right back i'll be right back
jamie kennedy screamed oh that's true i
was sad that's when
scream two happened to him oh yeah man i
mean
i'll be right back is uh they're usually
back though aren't they
nowadays they know enough to make a
self-aware thing
so uh yeah it's meta but not two metal
nine times out of ten they're usually
back oh yeah
why were you why'd you have this in
front of our mini fan
oh i'm so sorry because it's cold so you
wanna you wanna
that was a rhyme and it was a good one
and you did it you're
you're a poet and you didn't even know
it
i'll let you have that one i'll let you
have that all right i'll buy that for
you thank you eric
that's a really big tip too by the way
thank you darling i appreciate it
very much so yeah i think i think audi
uh filmmakers have become a lot more
aware of the i'll be right back trope
too
hey kirk players welcome to the chat
hello hello we did
cobra kai you can find the playlist on
our channel there magma yes
newly revamped thanks to the gregory
when season three comes out we will
cover that for youtube
hell's yeah and then deal with netflix
being like what the [ __ ] you all doing
what are you putting all these 80s songs
in here i was actually this
close before it was a little bit before
coven
uh i was i was joining cobra they wanted
me to
join the cast and i was like yeah buddy
um i earned that i'm the new hawk
all those reactions paid off and now i'm
on the series regular
miguel's older brother from spain i'll
buy that for a dollar um
no i i i was i remember do you remember
this they invited me to go host cobra uh
a q a
session in atlanta yeah for a cobra kai
and i was like yeah i got to do this and
i've never been to atlanta before but
then
a little coved happened so i don't know
what's happening with that
um i was trying to make sure it was i
was trying to get both of us because
uh john cover cobra kai season two for
even though i've seen season two he
covered it for patreon
so there's only proof that i saw it yeah
greg will never be exactly prove it to
you i just read the wikipedia
i just i just read the novelizations of
each episode
so much more to the canon nick doug
is saying um hey nick a doug love that
name nikki doug
pick a luck hey guys it's my birthday in
five days happy early birthday
days from now and i'm hosting a private
screening of tenet with my friends
what so i'm excited for that but a tv
show trope that i
disliked just happened in the show the
100
is when the creators kill off a
character with no payoff
be safe thank you i mean that's just a
letdown
yeah that's just a [ __ ] that's a
letdown i mean happy early birthday i
hope you have a really good social
distance i mean how are you holding a
private wait
wait a minute i hope no one kills you
off right before your birthday how are
you holding a private screening
yeah i was like do you have a theater do
you have a copy did you pirate the movie
how did you get a
copy of ten it's a screaming pirate like
a film printed copy
that makes no sense yeah how are you
doing this and how can we get in on the
action yeah can we attend this private
screening because i don't wanna
drive can you are you near can you lock
me in on zoom
can you do some chris nolan time space
bending [ __ ] to get us for you
telling people that you're holding a
private because you can't buy this on
video on demand
so how are you doing a private screening
attendant dude his yom tyrone is
actually here right now
he's just in the other room tyrone is
always with us he's always in our hearts
and here and in the bedroom
satisfying my woman one million sperm
cells
[Laughter]
but yes that is a disappointing voice
that is disappointing harry right there
um let's see here but thank you thank
you uh
nick a doug right where'd he go nicki
doug there he is nick doug happy early
birthday buddy
eric horseman back at it john can we
punch in on this
we can punch we're punching so people
can read it better because most people
watch from their phones
we can punch like it's no one's lunch
you got this john thanks you did it john
okay did it john
going up two we got okay bad horror
trope
bad horror trope number three would we
not be friends with tyrone magnus
dude because i mean
he's not broken one million subscribers
we're not allowed to make eye contact or
talk to him until we are too
it was a sad day for us when he hit a
million
especially for you i know how close you
guys are he sends you voice
he sends you voice texts every day like
i'll hear a voice text of tyrone like
once every six months
or something like that yeah every time
we text you he he never texts me he
he always voice messages he voice texts
like which
is like truth try not to leave some
trailers he knows well enough not to rob
you of those pipes
yeah bad horror trope number three jump
scares just
for the sake of jump scares best use of
jump scares haunting of hill house
there are some good ones that's true i
think jump scare you know there's two
jump scares i want to shout out though
with this truck i mean we i think we all
can agree that jump scares are very much
overused but they can be a lot of fun
yeah there's two jump scares i really do
want to point out hey
everyone there's two jump scares i want
to point i don't know if i've mentioned
this yet
everyone um
it is um yes the one in haunting a hill
house that is one of the scariest
if you guys haven't seen haunting of
hill house season one it's such a good
jump scare
that if you've seen haunting of hill
house season one and you talk to anyone
who's seen it
all you got to do is go that [ __ ]
jump scare right there though
that one jump scare right and everyone's
like that one oh yeah oh i don't i don't
want jump scooters that's a scary
reaction top five jump scooters
yeah that is uh that is a great jump
scare that guy yeah
i'll never forget yeah and i gotta give
kuda major kudos to this movie because
while the movie wasn't great and wasn't
received well
um i was revisiting uh some old trailers
for a very specific purpose that one day
you guys will find out why
is for the none and not the movie itself
but oh yeah we got shot the movie but
the way the trailer did it
because if you guys remember the first
trailer for the none
they said stay till the end stay till
the end it was all the watch that really
cool jump scare
and even though they're telling you stay
till the end you know it's a jump scare
it's gonna come
it's [ __ ] effective yeah it's a very
effective jump scare yes it is and when
i saw
crazy rich asians that those jump scares
those asians were jumping all over the
place
i'm scared of asians it was uh
they played the trailer for the nun
before we watched it and
uh which is the exact audience you want
to target right actually no it makes
sense romantic comedy couples couples
like to watch horror movies i like to
jump in each other's arms
so uh yeah they played that and everyone
in the theater jumped
everyone dude and it's one of those jump
scares that was so scary that
once everyone jumped i was like oh my
god you can hear all the murmurs in the
crowd and everyone talking about how
they just got scared by that
so yeah i would say uh i would say so
and yes
mirna in the chat watch the boys
absolutely
and also hashtag miranda watch the books
where the hell
is where did she go she's not here
anymore chase gardner
watch haunting of hill house and then
come when you come talk to us when you
see the jump scare
yes you'll know and thank you i was
great and it's always sunny in
philadelphia
i've always thought about doing a
documentary
kind of like what um uh jim carrey did
for his work on man on the moon when he
played andy kaufman yeah
i feel like i should do a documentary
about me playing kid number two
oh yeah on season one of that one
episode
underage drinking is the title of it and
it's always sunny in philadelphia it's
always funny when greg
shoots a bit part for it's always sunny
in philadelphia i became
kid number two dude i didn't there was a
week where i didn't know you at all i
was like who is this kid
i'm like do we go to the same school i'm
like i'm just john but this kid's a
whole different kid
he's not the kid i knew he must be some
other kid number two
eric back at it thank you so much dude
freaking rock man
you are you you you you are 80
of the contributions to the totality of
the live streams
you are our rock you're the band-aid in
our boat
you keep us safe out here man uh eric is
saying more bad tropes
woman waking up ever
in life woman waking up in full makeup
yes
this is great this is a great trope song
not a great trope it's a great one a
great bad trope to point out
any time we're reacting to anything and
if it happens
i i have to call it out it's in the
hospital and we're in the bedroom
woman waking up in full makeup like
lisa and supernatural when couples wake
up in the morning and i'm immediate and
immediately kiss hello morning breath
hello freak [ __ ]
um yes that's true that is true that's
that is true don't have morning
and uh but yeah anytime in movie i think
the boys recently did it
and um and then and yeah supernatural
but it's every movie and show
it's like let it let let these people
wake up the way they were looking
you know why the hell not and if you see
me in the morning my hair looks
bananas all right it is like my hair is
awful my hair's already almost
impossible to manage
imagine what this looks like in the
morning it's just frizzy
zapping around it's a roller coaster
i've had to start sleeping with my hair
and braids during the summer
simply because i would sweat so much
to the point where i once had to have a
friend
d-mat my hair for a half an hour yes so
yeah
it's it struggles in the morning and
it's not represented on film
these are real world problems that we
are describing to you guys
and i wish other countries
could and try to understand the
struggles that we
have you know while there's fires going
on
fire is going on various protests around
economic collapses everywhere and
protests everywhere
they don't get how hard it is to wake up
in the morning with our hair
you know sometimes enough hair and some
sweat is a recipe for disaster
haven't been watching walking dead gotta
be honest hashtag
greg watch the walking dead your hair is
always perfectly curled tm says you do
you think i curl
it greg sleeps in her hair rollers
myself
you're like straight i
olivia comes home in a tie in like those
old time glasses and you're putting your
hair up and making a meatloaf
robbie brown thank you
thank you robbie brown for your tip
buddy hey guys
first time tuning in but worst trope
is the smart guy explaining something
and someone's saying
english please oh please if you guys
haven't seen the sketch yes yes
that i came across because um you
discovered this sketch
i i wrote a sketch forever ago that
would honestly still work today and i
this was not
not get us canceled most of our sketches
that we that we do
most of them are like we're getting
ready to do a reaction or something to
put up
but most of the sketches that we do are
we're just greg and john and playing
a riff on that right and uh and this
sketch was like characters and it was
inspired by
um the the this the this trope that i
hear
in like every [ __ ] cia hunting down
someone movie
uh it doesn't give away at all what the
sketch is really all about but
it started with i want to know where he
sleeps i want to know where he eats
that's where the idea came and then i
came in in the middle of writing that
sketch
i wanted i wanted to make sure no one's
done that this sketch that i i had
uh that i wrote up uh and like there's a
sketch out there
called english please and it's the smart
guy
hitman and every time the tech people
are trying to explain something
because it goes english you just never
guessed it i don't want to ruin the
sketch review
just type in english please sketch it's
a
really really funny well shot
hilariously timed sketch um
uh yeah english please that is a that is
a common trope
and uh i i don't think i've ever said
that because it just sounds so
condescending yeah
like [ __ ] all that learning you did
excuse me i'm gonna empower myself for
not understanding this complexity can
you imagine someone saying
that's like explaining something to you
in the deep thought process
you're just like english english
geez egghead wants his
bookie wook um well no we shot the boys
but our editor
he's been very busy uh lately and we i
have to res
usually eric uh nerd chronic like his
turnaround rate is usually the most like
incredible timing um and uh but he is
now
since he's now the full-time editor for
the movie trivia showdown
so while working when he's the only
editor i currently trust to cut up our
uh for these reactions but bradley blood
so i've been talking with you too buddy
we gotta try it soon
but um so he has the footage we shot it
yesterday
and so it should be up tomorrow for
everyone who's asking about uh the boys
english please english i love that one
man that's a funny one
well it always just brings me right back
to that joy of watching that sketch
all right uh before we go back to the
super chats and stuff let's see what's
going on
in the regular in the regular chat here
uh let's see here hey creo
nice to see you here rwby series okay
which movie you love but everyone hated
hmm
um wild wild west well that's a good
love wild wild west
i think that's a great wild wild i think
it's funny and clever and inventive
no one gets it but me and nissa how's
you how you doing dear
chappy chappie's a good call i like that
movie
um should you watch the boys yes miranda
you should
hashtag the nun was scary that's good
john drinking alcohol this is a real
this is how real live stream engagements
instead of trying to make it an
entertaining time if you're just like
okay this
yo watch batman one more time sucker
punch
and also when someone gets shot as long
as you take out the bullet
is really what's going on in the head
and you're looking for something to rip
off
that's an interesting thing though uh
i've noticed this like i don't know if
it's a trope really but it is like oddly
disturbing to me now
that like yeah there's so much you can
do in action
sci-fi movies like depicting violence
but as long as you just don't show blood
or like
you know bullet wounds like you could
just do whatever and like they can
capture it in ways that feel
so gritty personal and harsh but it's
still like pg-13
there's no blood you know in the boys
not the boys uh mulan
same difference i often get mulan and
the boys confuse them
huey has chi all this time you don't
just don't know it yet but in mulan
i i'm well aware it's a disney movie
right
we all are i couldn't help but get
distracted
by like everyone's getting sliced and
diced and i'm like what's
why is there no there's not even a hint
of blood in it that's not a hint of
of the the the cost of the stakes the
the reason this is so intense nobody
makes me bleed my own blood
we shared this dope trip in a recent um
recent podcast on patreon
um why don't you start it off john and
i'll say with the one that i filled in
afterwards based off of the one that you
said so john take away another
dope trip hopefully no one has to wait
wait a minute it's the one with the
the the uh when someone's talking loud
oh yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
there's a perfect example you watch like
transformers
the last night i believe i'm still a
little hazy as to which transformers
movie it is
there's two giant like several stories
tall robots meeting in the desert with
like
the cia to cut a deal and they turn to
each other and they're like we're gonna
[ __ ] double-cross these guys
and i'm like they're they're right down
there and the characters somehow
don't hear them yeah and that's the
silliest thing i could like it and it
happens in other ways but that was like
the most extreme example of just
earshot does not exist in movies and
nobody works at the hospital
and then the one i was saying on top of
that
is i hate it it really pulls me out
and and properties that i love
intellectual properties
i'm not talking about like a hospital
building
[Laughter]
this trip mall down the street all right
that is a choice property
i could own that mr robson you can rent
those units out
they say treat your audience like like
they're smarter
than what you're going to do or yeah you
know treat them smart but i'm like no
they might get me confused here
they might think i'm talking about a
parking lot or something yeah yeah this
piece of property
hey we are also a real estate channel
with all those collabs we do with our
buddy brandon
um the uh the the the
the trope that i'm not a big fan of and
it's in every
everything is you could be at a loud
party you could be at a club there's a
lot of booming music
whenever they enter the scene of the
party or the club
they establish it's it's loud in there
it's booming loud in there
and then when a character goes up to
talk to another character
for some reason they just talk in the
same tone the same pitch that jon and i
are talking in right now
and as if they're in some kind of quiet
secluded area or if there's like a
pocket of silence around
the music just goes lower for some
reason
background noise you know this is a
music bed the movie the matrix does it
that's my favorite movie
and it's when when trinity goes to at
the rave and then trinity goes and
whispers into neo's ear
like you're looking for the truth what
truth the matrix you know
that's true yeah in real life i'm like
you'd at least be pushing down here on
the ear
yeah to try to like close it muffle out
some of the other
isolated yeah but they live in the
matrix that's part of trinity's powers
oh yeah
she can she can isolate into his eardrum
oh oh and then there was the other the
other other one where uh
the the kids standing and screaming
as whatever you know like a hole opens
up in the earth or like
a monster walks toward them or something
and they just don't
do anything other than stan scream and
wait for tom cruise or whoever the hero
is to swipe him up
i hate eavesdropping characters too i
think you always get the most
they walk in um
in the chat is saying um no one knows my
secret the main character says loudly in
the hallway
and it in a lot of movies and stuff it's
like the character will walk in just on
time to get the info like to be
yeah the exact dialogue to either make
them feel like they're not accepted
yeah or to get the information to
properly move along the plot
you know yeah there are so many things
that i'm just like if you guys
talked about this for like half a second
upon the misunderstanding
yeah uh also just just really quick
uh lee ass says worst trope rob zombies
dialogue
i feel personally attacked by that but
also
yeah it's a trope of rob zombie movies
that rob zombie movies have rob zombie
dialogues
mirna and the chat is saying villains
that never die are just
ugh have you seen the halloween kills
trailer that everyone
asked us to every live stream if we've
seen the trailer have we have you seen
it yet have we seen it yet do we do we
do it yet
that's my favorite i'm just not as big
of a fan of that
opening of that being the opening scene
just like
the fire trucks and ambulances going
i don't know what it is about it i don't
really want to take the time to
articulate my
my reasoning on it today but there's
something about that that just feels
like it undercuts the impact of the
ending of the last one to me
if that's your very first opening scene
in the next movie
is it just a continuation of that scene
yeah it's just the same moment
but [ __ ] fire trucks and ambulances
are here you know
see i could i could be down with it if
they had some kind of prologue
and then like after the title card we
cut to them yeah or something like that
where it's like this is the main action
but there's some other mood setter to
start with
slashers man here's another there's
another trope that john and i always
point out whenever it happens in movies
and shows
is when there's like an alien invasion
there's city destruction
happening whether it be sky beam or
aliens using
lasers stuff and then the crowd starts
dispersing and they're all running away
panicking and then there's a child oh
yeah a
singular child child stands and screams
stands or doesn't even scream just
looks and then hero hero grabs
child it takes them to the parent and
nine times out of ten the parent doesn't
even say
thank you yeah that's the other part yes
they just never ever acknowledge
like my child would have been dead in it
i wouldn't have been any help to that
situation and maddie's saying in the
chat i hate it when the parent never
believes the kid like listen to them
it's your kid
yes give them a chance one piece of
props i will give to the movie
eight-legged freaks
is they they do make a point out of that
and you know what other movie handled
that pretty well
was the movie that del toro produced
that not a lot of people
saw oh don't be afraid of the dark don't
be afraid the katie holmes one
yeah yeah with a little girl i handle
that one pretty well yeah
anyway we got some super chats that we
are of course behind on greg and john
style so let's get to it john
let's jump on it go away title come back
all right
so next one day we will be those
youtubers who only
go through all right so we gotta have
efficient livestream we got
peter pacheco in the building with the
captain
spalding avatar thank you peter
appreciate the tip buddy
what's he saying john the wilhelm scream
in particular every action movie
the other day the sky reminded me of the
parademon scene in bvs how's the
portuguese coming
oh man so good i'm not ready just yet
though because i want it to make you
like
full-on orgasm when i do pull it out he
he was going to
study portuguese the other day but he
ended up watching
david lynch's dunes i watched david
lynch's because uh is his trailer coming
out for the new dune he wanted to feel
acquainted appreciate
the homework you put in john paid off in
the end
it did a little bit uh the wilhelm
scream i don't know why that is a go-to
scream
you know what there's a there's a laugh
track in sitcoms and i'm
very curious to know if
anyone in this stream has ever heard
this laugh and i've heard it in every
sitcom that features a studio audience
i like other than snl because that's a
live audio but in uh
and friends how i met your mother or
whatever sitcom i've ever seen
i hear this laugh at least once and
they do um on on sitcoms they do
actually it sometimes enhance the laugh
track some shows don't even have a left
track but they they throw it in there
they throw the laugh track in there and
and even on friends they've done it
i've seen behind the scenes which i
think is a terrible thing to reveal in
your behind the scenes that sometimes
you add a little bit of laughter
but it's a terrible thing to show your
audience
um but uh there are problems for the
honest dude there's this one laugh
and it's the same laugh i've heard it in
all these shows and i'm like okay that's
a fake
fake laugh that's one of the add-on
tracks that goes
it's it's like really like it's the come
down after all the laughs are going down
and you just hear
one last echoing laugh that goes
it's that it's it's old specific laugh
didn't think that joke was funny
yes um you know what i would be i
wouldn't be
surprised if they had because i've never
thought much about it but they have to
have just libraries of different things
special oh my goodness and how much time
that must take
that's true yeah thank you chase guard
thank you peter pacheco
and thank you chase for the tip buddy
always chasing our heart in the gardens
and if you don't know the world you have
heard it bro oh you guys have heard it
hell yeah yeah go look it up if you
don't know it cause you know it
you've heard you know the wilhelm
scriptures even in venom there are yeah
well that's the thing is there are is
like and some studios have like
libraries of them but there are
if you yeah enough movies you'll hear
certain screams certain like cat
sounds that are all like canned and the
same and yeah uh chase
gardener worst trope for me it's
gardener
gardener william it's willow
garnier fructis what is it john let's
hear it buddy
worst trope for me the main character in
a movie or tv show running through a
forest
and suddenly falling and breaking the
most important thing in the scene
which is usually a car that can teleport
there
based off of a device that you have yes
why are they always breaking the the
ability of the car that has the ability
to appear
yeah the special time juice damn they're
always busting the
you know what i mean guys the space flux
capacitor
that is true they and uh because there
is the falling over trope but then there
is also the trope of you break like you
smash your phone or some [ __ ]
cell phone service not working which is
a very reasonable applause
and um plausible trip so guys has the
camera quality been better for you this
stream
has the audio been better think been
better has it been better for you guys
we would like feedback on this
is it it's not delacing red blue green
is it instant feedback
we are a corporate as well um we are we
speak to reject hr i see some people
have heard that laugh track before
tom murphy t murph which just sounds
like a like a like a like a
70s cop character oh yeah detective tom
murphy
murphy i want your badge and your
imaginary guy
you're off the case murmur you're too
invested in this
go home you're too close to the case see
your wife which would make you very
emotionally invested in make you'd
probably do a better job it's a crack in
this case but you're too close
too close tom murphy you're costing me
money
he says i used to like the simpsons but
when will the curtains close on the show
all right i'm sorry you don't like that
sorry i trope like the simpsons
continuing in real life i'm sick of this
trip with the simpsons continuing
um i don't know i kind of like that the
simpsons is the never ending show
yeah i always hope that it's the kind of
thing where yeah just like it'll
periodically get good and then it'll get
kind of meh and then maybe it'll get
good again
i don't know varun kumar hey hey it's me
again requesting to bring back thank you
varun
um appreciate it it's me again
requesting bringing back cat alvarado
i'll have you know that i had a text
message exchange earlier with cat
alvarado today
and it looks like next week you'll
probably get your wish fulfilled
because she's been staying home with
mommy and daddy this whole time
i know she's safe she is covered free
yeah man so yeah you're getting your
wish well that's the best kind of super
chat answer you could get
today your standards the living
tombstone
john's best friend of all time how you
going to read his
his trope what's his dope trope in my
opinion
worst trope in a lot of movies are
terrible transitions to act three like a
forced reveal
where the part or the protagonist has to
be like but i can explain
and then all the stuff comes out and
yeah the transition out of the always
lost and all that
stuff yeah i to act three is the hard
one man
it's the hardest one to crack okay let
me read this again
worst trope in a lot of movies are
terrible transitions to
act three like a forced reveal where the
protagonist has to be like
but i can explain i'm a little bit
confused on this one
can you explain it john do you get it
well i mean i guess it's like that
uh is it when you know the characters
basically like made such a mess for
themselves out of so many like you know
various
deceits and hijinks that you know yeah
all is lost at this moment and now we're
gonna break into act three is they're
gonna try and
bring everybody back together or
something
no am i reaching sure i'm not sure i
don't i honestly don't fully understand
what this trope is
well you know we should make a movie and
use it but like
to get you to act i don't know yeah i
don't understand it text him don't you
have to first don't you know this person
yes i do okay
i'm gonna find out for yeah on the line
get them on the line let me get to the
bottom of this trope there are a lot of
bats the real rejects manager
anissa and bradley and rosie beatty are
the real rejects managers
oh goodness carrot parrot cluck
parrot cluck trope i hate erica
tuesday's saying explain nuance you up
and yes john gotti yeah john got it all
right yeah yeah yeah
that's why he's your best friend i don't
know him
especially in those movies that like i i
found it funny and you yeah
be like being a spill fan back in the
day i know they used to get like really
uh like upset over characters like jason
biggs the player jason bateman would
play who are like those
guys who are trying to be nice or
whatever and who are you know constantly
like being pushovers and and you know
like creating these crazy comedic stakes
and yeah like what i can explain
so uh yeah living tombstone has a
verified check mark
i know oh yeah living tombstone has a
whole
like youtube like three million
followers that they have more followers
than us they're gonna steal the
spotlight from our live streams that's
why i hate whenever jaby kawaii jumps in
here
well i leave the stream jaby you're
taking all my attention
i don't know if jaby has as much as i
mean when i do that to other youtubers
no no no but when other youtubers do
that to us like living tombstone mm-hmm
i'm just trying to steal your friend now
john is this tactic where did
you get off of having a following
um so parrot cluck
parrot cluck thank you parrot cluck what
a [ __ ] cool name
trope i hate if there's a boy and a girl
no matter the age they fall in love yeah
i'm sick of
watching these like adult women fall in
love with little boys and movies man
every [ __ ] movie yeah it just keeps
happening man this this horrible
hollywood male fantasy of just like
little boys need to have
grown adult women in their lives i'm
kidding i'm kidding oh golly i love that
particularly
but the trip that you're talking about
um i get what you're saying and
yeah it's usually for the female
character too it's like they'll make the
like we don't need to assign a love
interest
in all movies yeah don't need a love
interest every single time
and maybe once in a while it would be
nice if like even though we're trying to
pretend like tom cruise isn't in his 50s
that like his
love interest is not also like 19 right
it'd be cool sometimes to see that just
keep getting the really hot young girls
but then again i feel like women still
like tom cruise he's the kind of guy
you're women
women you're all why are you always on
about women's women
i want to be one uh but thank you parrot
cluck the love interest trope
we don't always need it we don't need
love
i'm sick of seeing movies and shows
where people are like
step brothers or step sisters and
and that's just okay for them to hook up
now
because they're only step siblings
and they rarely go out of their way to
be like
it's it's kind of [ __ ] up huh
yes they never go out of her way to just
maybe explain a little bit
of well we're not we're not blood
related so maybe it's okay like have a
conversation about it
actually i'm just supposed to assume
it's okay i have a romantic comedy
concept in mind where it doesn't start
where their step
but it starts biological it's an abscess
love story it's the first time you're
gonna fall in love with this man
underrepresented okay no no uh
yeah but yeah that gets into some kind
of territory like that
but i won't get too deep into it in case
someone wants to steal this
one hundred thousand dollar idea
anissa's got another trope in movies
which is when police and miller why is
bradley leaving
brad what are you doing you made the
banner bradley is it your wife
she is ruining your friendship with us
ever since you got this wife before we
met you
she's just been trying to take you away
yeah i feel like your attention has
really been
yeah and i can't tell your allegiances
lie
wow bro way to be a bro another trophy
in movies thank you anissa we're
benissah
another trope in movies is when the
police military show up late and not
need it anymore
lol example monster squad favorite movie
watch it it's great
or or an ending
i [ __ ] hate which i i i'm under the
impression you're on board for
i like it but i understand he already
knows what i'm talking about
he already knows yeah i i i do i'm a fan
although i do accept some criticism of
it yes the mist
i hate that and i just i don't i don't
like it
i especially the fact that if you like
you mean to tell me you couldn't even
hear
that [ __ ] yeah like it which was uh two
minutes away from showing up
this was made of styrofoam this is
really a soundproof mist
damn there's like a thousand people
coming your way they're
just yeah they're like 30 feet away
thousand ninjas
it's like tanks and trucks that's a
trope i like
is when like in one moment like a room
you've been in for a long time all of a
sudden ninjas just come out of every
shadow
yeah that's a cool like antennae
that no one was expecting yeah that no
one expected to
should have been expected to expecting
john's not drunk are you drunk are you
drinking alcohol
uh this has like a little bit of alcohol
but it's just like a sparkling seltzer
well
these alcoholics they're always trying
to downplay how much they drink
i am slashed no mark leech
cabin in the woods mark leech my friend
oh nissa hated the missed ending thank
you anissa i mean i i would assume you
do especially since you submitted the
troop
well we got two votes so you must be
both correct justice for nicki i'm just
kidding i love your wife i'm sure she's
hotter than you bradley
and you're already pretty hot so that's
like wow you're hot bradley
uh mark leach cabin uh i read the last
one johnny can read it cabin in the
woods is a horror film trope
it's a smart enough it's smart enough to
know how to put
it into the film it's the ultimate trope
ps bring back cat alvarado
so you're saying that the actual like
like having a cabin in the woods that
is the setting is a trope yeah which it
is
but are you also saying that cabin in
the woods is a film that just has like
way many tropes in it because that is
also true i mean the whole idea was to
present all the tropes and then subvert
all the tropes
which is what they did pretty well so
yeah mark if you guys haven't seen cabin
in the woods you're doing yourself a
disservice i feel like probably everyone
who's here now
has seen cabin in the woods yeah but
yeah and then follow it up with the mist
yeah follow the miss right afterwards
double feature yourself
in that order and uh no thank you eric i
mean i'm
uh yeah if i were to fight a pizza
during this live stream in this weather
i'd be like
i i'd crash we won't talk you know what
it will be though it'll be it'll be
it'll be when we're like this is the
last day we're doing the channel people
after 15 years of supernatural we are
shutting down the channel
yeah that was all that's holding it
together
but thank you though seriously one of
these days we will take you up
um a cabin in the woods put it into the
film
who we got next fen cycladine pcp
pod pop culture not pod culture pop
culture podcast
how's it going horror movie trope
friends and family automatically think
the main character is lying about
something or
someone or something trying to kill them
right right
yeah movies go out of their way to
discredit main characters like that or
have characters kind of pass off [ __ ]
i feel like halloween 2018 did it
tried to work with that in a way that
didn't
fully come together but wait a minute
okay pop culture
podcast first of all thank you he has a
great podcast
which i was on and he wants you to come
yes we're gonna sort that out horror
movie trope friends and family
automatically think the main character
is lying about someone or something or
trying to kill them or trying to like
over rationalize
well if the cops believe them huh or the
dad
or the husband yeah
then the movie's journey would be over
right away
yeah i know i mean i think every horror
movie should just be they go to the cop
the cop believes them the cop comes in
gets killed oh [ __ ]
and i gotta go the next person deante is
pointing it out and um
yeah invisible man did do it it's all
but depending on how it's handled and
like
i to me to me that is really an
execution thing
because that movie is about gaslighting
because yeah because sometimes it can be
like just give your kid a chance you
think your kid's just crazy
listen to your kid maybe the kid's onto
something yeah yeah
yeah yeah but then um or like your wife
or whatever
but in the invisible man the way how
they dealt with
the part of them not believing her toyed
with
i mean we know it's real that he's
really invisible but how that dealt
so much with is this all in her head is
she crazy she's losing her mind how it
became an allegory for abuse and feeling
haunted by past traumas
um that they they worked with
what could have just been a trope and
really made it a big part of its dna
yeah and i think when you do that it's
really effective hashtag greg deep
well that's that's literally like what
makes one of those twists like it was in
his head the whole time
he was the killer it's like that can be
a trope when you just throw it in out of
nowhere or you can
i'm not gonna name movies but you know
the ones that earn it really make that
part of the story you walk around in
that psychosis
yeah yeah also i see i see one in the
main chat that just says
uh from black chocolate says aliens seem
to only invade the us
and especially new york aliens hate new
york's
there's usually a shot of a village in
china a village so that way they could
put that movie in china
and the capitol records building yeah i
also hate the capitol records building
it is it is always the u.s yeah
and what that's what i love this maybe
the version on arrival they just wanted
to communicate because i'm like why are
the aliens always come here just being
like
[ __ ] you guys what are these ugly
buildings
kill them ugh um what's going on
sometimes you guys say things in the
chat when you're going back
that get me like concerned that there's
an argument happening
eric and he's hurt no um
i hope it's not because of greg being
balls deep chase gardner
chase garner back at it again superhero
trope in the flash tv show
the flash needs to fight a speedster the
flash saying i am not the fastest man
alive
but i love the flash show yep
if i was still watching the flash i
would really connect with you on this
side
i stopped around midpoint of season five
i just i was like i'm not into this show
anymore but i hear it's
good still um but then again people love
season
they were loving those seasons that i
wasn't loving so that's why i haven't
been keeping up with it because i'm like
i just don't feel the love for the show
but yeah after watching five and a half
seasons so i will say
that is a 100 percent accurate trope
just like how attack on titan aaron the
main character is always getting
kidnapped
dude what's up with that what's up with
the kidnapping yo
you know what trip i'm sick of movies
that are about hostages
about a hostage situation and there are
people being held hostage yeah
yeah i think they're like eating about
the hostages yeah i'm
sick of it hostage movies
i'll give you three hostages what else
would you do with that
it's a it's a mcguffin hey anissa eric
everyone at discord and who's listening
to this right now
here i'm here no matter what they say
words might bring you down from time to
time
but you know get a better self-image
a little bit and go to therapy observe
your thoughts
mds omega ew you know every time i hear
see mds omega i constantly think of dmt
but that's not what it is
i think of metal deer solid i hate the
trope
of trying to certainly i think a metal
deer saw
no deer uh i hate the
uh no i read the last one you go joseph
i hate the trope of trying to survive in
a zombie show or movie
just don't give up
yeah just just accept your losses
accurate
and then the movie would follow the
zombie for the rest of the movie yeah
there are some zombie tropes i just
don't get like what
like how they how it's a superpower
you know what zombie trope i don't like
what i don't like is especially with
zombies
in particular i know this is common with
all monster movies
it's like if they're you know moving
[ __ ] out of the way then a zombie
appears and bites them or something like
that
if the zombie appears and when the
zombie appears it's just like
yeah right away they and they get them
right yeah and in my mind when i'm
watching it i'm going
what's that zombie making [ __ ] noise
before you [ __ ] did anything
you making noise too before you moved it
out of the way wouldn't the zombie have
been
making noise at that point yeah before
you got
that close to move that curtain you know
or yeah or you think it would be
distracted by you moving around or
something
yeah zombies man but yes
they like dramatic pauses that's the one
thing they have brain function left for
uh let's see here hey if people ask
about the discord
the discordo checks better be answering
anissa back in the chat she got a dual
dual chat here
all right a movie trope where the girl
guy
goes back to the toxic relationship then
after finally realized what they'd done
and they should have gone to the good
one and she also followed up with when
y'all come to texas to show you all some
southern hospitality
greg if you do choose to get married who
is going to be your best man
it's going to be a very awkward
conversation between john and my brother
shavi coach what i'm going to do is i'm
going to get a pool cue break it in
half on my thighs
uh i but that would be the perfect it
wouldn't be a great wedding without a
dark knight
battle royale to be your best man
uh but that would be the answer and then
uh the uh the court but yes would love
to come to texas experience some of that
southern hospitality you could take us
to joe rogan's spaceship studio oh
the weird-ass looking spaceship studio
that's one of the rare cases
in a set at a set change because most of
the time like guys
chill out all right we're still getting
the content we're still getting the co i
don't know if you guys watch the joe
rogan show
but remember we're still getting the
content it's still a podcast it's mainly
a podcast
i i don't i rarely watch it
i'm usually listening but then when i
saw the new set on joe rogan i was like
this [ __ ] looks [ __ ]
weird have you seen it no like spaceship
he moved to texas and it was like the
spaceship looking set
and i saw it and i i really do i know
not everyone likes joe rogan i do like
his podcast generally speaking
i just disagree with him on a lot of
feeling good i always had to [ __ ]
copy out with james
joe i disagree with him on a lot of
things but
i do find him very entertaining but he
does have a new set that is just
bizarre it's very bizarre yeah uh you
should check it out sometimes
it's not a green screen it's it's a
practical set but it looks like a green
screen the way they did it
um but uh yeah i i think uh southern
sometimes this is what you know
but in all seriousness sometimes this is
uh this trope though
can be uh a thing that happens in a lot
i see it all the time in real life i see
it
all the time and i'm i know someone
jacob's dealing with it
bella never goes to jacob she just
doesn't they always
like people people often are drawn to
the
toxic i what i don't like about this
what i don't like about this
trope of where the guy girl goes back to
the toxic relationship when they should
have gone to the good one
or they realize it late in the movie or
whatever is that
usually what gets them to go to realize
they have to go to the good relationship
is not a character growth arc that i
truly feel has earned a lot of time
i think in real at least in real life
it's usually takes a lot of letting go
of like past things and
finding your self-worth and
self-confidence and then you're like now
i deserve someone who's good for me
and then you attract that person right
or you realize oh there's something good
for me right here
the whole time where as in movies and
stuff
it's usually like i don't know the
[ __ ] guy
there's something so horrible like oh i
should have been with a good one you
know there's some kind of yeah there's
usually like a
switch flip epiphany where they you know
realize
a thing and then go back to that person
and so like yeah it doesn't feel like a
full-on character thing so much as like
oh we needed a plot point to get them
back together
exactly yeah uh guys we're gonna wrap
this stream up in about what time is it
in about
15 minutes 75 minutes 15 to 20 minutes
are gonna be wrapping the stream up just
to give you guys a heads up
yeah yeah sarah campbell back in the
chat ooh
when people leave their houses and don't
lock their doors
like all the canadians everyone in
canada she's not talking about a movie
she's talking about a canada trip if
they had a slasher movie in canada
besides uh my bloody valentine you could
have every guardian killed before the
movie is over because no one's locking
those doors
oh yeah that's true people just leave
their doors hanging open
all night in canada or even in the show
friends they have their adorable
uh yeah that's a good one though our
next boys reaction of some uh xx master
thief acts in the chats asking will be
up tomorrow
should be i'll hit up our editor
uh but yeah thank you sarah yeah hillary
b
i think it's two super chats for
contributor thank you muchos pay
attention to that [ __ ]
muchas gracias hillary b what's up
hillary pickle rank every time i yell
like that no that's all i hear in my
oh here in my own head pickle rick
pickle hillary
love you guys hope everything is going
better for y'all
well thank you hillary thank you i'd say
things have been going pretty good you
know
i'm enjoying the stream we've been
pretty on topic for the majority of the
stream it's been a smooth stream
and what's crazy about this stream that
i feel makes this topic unique
is that not only have you guys been
consistently contributing tropes that we
hadn't
considered or thought of or to put on
our own personal list
but we've even been coming up with more
as we've been going to
off off the dome so this has been a
really consistent live stream so i
appreciate that
hey hey you want to know another trope
yeah
i'm i'm feeling nice okay okay
actually though get to the trump truck i
tell you what the trope is but
it's a little above your pay grade i'll
buy that for a dog
unedited banter in movies
judd where you at mirna i've been
reading some of your comments in the
stream and she gave us a i thought that
was a dog paw i really thought that was
a dog pop but that's what
i was about to go through this whole
thing in my head of what's a dog paw
but then uh yeah that's our hearts thank
you thank you mirna that means a lot
thank you so much
she is from uh audalia australia
australia
if you join our patreon that's a that's
the easiest way to get to the discord
um thank you mirna it's a lovely name by
the way yeah
anissa's saying a dream of mine is to
watch a horror movie with you all
especially
john oh you would love it you can do all
those famous reactions like faces and
noises
i can go and i can
breathe loud that's my favorite john
trope
breathing i never say that about you
when we're reacting though
you know why because we have had fun and
i can't hear his friends
yes yes so i breathe to my heart's
content but you get really focused
you get really focused in the movies and
you breathe really loud that's why
social distancing going to the theaters
with you experiences are going to be
great what do you think of that scene
i can't hear [ __ ] over here oh yeah all
dahlia that's right
odd alien billion dollars anisa
that's right let's see should we go back
to the chat for a hot second yeah man
for a hot secundo of course
while we do can i navigate while you
read some of the the latest
ones here oh because we do got to wrap
up heckles in a little bit but i want to
make sure we get to all
all the tips that we've gotten yes
bradley this is the real rejects
experience you get it here
all in imax 3d uh yeah next boy's
reaction we talked about that
when a simple five to ten minute
conversation could easily solve the
conflict of the movie that happens a lot
especially in like
madcap comedies i feel like yeah uh
thanos i'm the inevitable hulk give me a
real fight
tm i hate when people breathe breathing
is so cliche
it is man everyone's doing it everyone
just won't stop breathing and movements
come on man or circulate their blood
like how true i saw the title for don't
breathe and i was like oh finally i'm
moving
stop breathing and half the movie
they're still breathing much breathing
in this movie what a bunch of [ __ ]
this is false advertisement fetty
alvarez shouts out i know he's watching
it all right guys
uh so we are not going to uh thank you
to everyone who's contributed to the
super chat and the stream labs
um it's it meant a lot but we want to
finish up the last of them right now
and we got quite a few left so we've got
some ground to cover
oh yeah we got some grounded cover to
keep up with all right don't worry we'll
also still read the comments in between
and all that
so we got a vampires be like huh
all right oh reactions the tongue punch
fart box
deontay whoa whoa whoa okay this one
this one getting shot
omar getting shot getting shot yeah
getting shot or stabbed uses liquor to
sterilize makeshift surgery tools
somehow here his friend with very little
medical experience
is very good at stitching no infections
and sleep seems to be
a great healing method yes all of these
are a plus yes that was great it was
great we pointed out i will say i know a
lot of people didn't like this movie but
i thought
project power actually had like jamie
foxx is injured and then he's getting
stitched up by
what's that actress's name the one who
we dominique fishback
dominique fishback yeah incredible
lawrence fishberg lawrence
fishburn or dominic toretto one of the
two
so uh dominique fishback when she's
stitching up jamie foxx
she does give a bit of a justification
to how she knows how to do this
let me add on to this though tom punch
fart box why is it always a
vet they go to i know it's always a vet
whenever
a character's injured and they gotta
keep this under the radar they always go
to a vet
mm-hmm every time like one of you guys
in one of these movies has to know at
least one person in the medical field
who works on humans
or worse [ __ ] there must be a human
hospital
somewhere nearby yeah you know how come
everyone in abilities
in these movies is close to a
veterinarian
uh flev is back yes
he says the pants thing too
pants the pants thing too pants thing
like people getting pantsed
people wearing pants i don't know the
pants thing to me having did we make a
joke about having pants
i don't know pants are pretty pretty
cliche though everyone's wearing
them i'm not sure if you have you got to
clear it up with the chats
have you seen this even ladies are
wearing pants now
see
um xx master thief x i don't want to
spoil what our thoughts were or
reactions were on uh the boys
the next episode but yeah loved that
[ __ ]
i did everything with the chameleon yeah
doppelganger
double genga nick doug back at it we
asked him earlier in the stream how the
hell are you holding a private screening
of tennant
he has an answer for us thanks nick doug
a theater near me
let lets you host a private screening of
a new movie or classics
oh how cool
that's the best which just started with
theaters reopening
oh that's really smart oh my god that's
great time that's great we gotta
fly out to where you are i am near your
county and if both of you guys wanted to
come i have two free tickets for you
guys it will be on thursday i could dm
you
oh maybe
maybe oh my goodness but i cannot watch
this
i cannot watch this without olivia i
can't watch it without my girlfriend
that's my that's my one rule all right
and i don't know if
john would be allowed to go and that
wouldn't be i'm not your girlfriend yeah
that's not my doing john would have to
run this by the people who he lives with
first
they're at risk but we'll talk oh yeah
it'll be good though
we'll talk maybe i've already done it
though this is really great
yeah but i i might want to go to imax
though to be honest
but i appreciate that nica doug that's
really sweet of you hells yeah either
way contact us
you just sound like a good person to
know if you can rent out a theater
imagine what else
yeah i have doran back at it don't like
people in films watching black and white
films on tv like is it just
a rights issue or what i don't believe
all these teams or cinephiles
like especially in like small
countries i mean they exist but there's
always like the biggest cinephiles out
there
they've got to exist though there's a
good part of our subscriber base we'll
talk to us from like
small towns of missouri like i don't
know a lot of people in film and that's
why i love watching your channel you
know
so it does got to exist it does have to
be real yeah but but you know
it does pull me out it's funny how most
movies are about those kids
yeah yeah yeah yeah like this might be
more of an editing technique but i like
transitional scenes gives a different
flow to the episode fair enough and the
thing that i have to say about the thing
with like especially with kids or high
school where they have like their tech
or theater or film department
and they all they really know film i was
like i know that exists and i imagine
that
writers a lot of the screenwriters
probably have a background that
from their childhood that felt that way
so that's probably what they're
projecting or putting into those scripts
in that time you know what i mean truth
that g true
the a t but thanks phleb flevy
flavorless eric horseman
the main man thank you buddy thanks
darling really appreciate it dude
overused trope in so many shows and
movies
will they won't they the boys friends
cheers that's true i feel like in real
life now
people kind of just do it they do they
do
they they will well the will they won't
they i think is especially overused on
sitcoms oh yeah that's like a classic
that's like a classic producer
note thing that you need like yeah we
gotta do this
and that's why i really respect how the
office did
it because a big part of the office
was because i agree this is an annoying
trophy it was yeah it was pam and jim
would you say paying it off paying those
off yeah actually
they said pam it off
um you know pam and jim get together i
think season
three is when it gets there or at the
end of there
and it actually made their relationship
stronger and i think
like chandler and monica i never really
viewed that as a strong will they won't
they they just kind of started hooking
up and got together and they became this
beloved couple
but specifically the office i thought
was one of the best at showing that you
can have them get together
and you can keep the show strong yeah
until steve carell leaves you can
you keep the show strong oh
yeah you can't lose your head yeah you
can't walk around without a head-on
and uh olivia has a hilarious tick tock
by the way
oh dude hilarious blow up her account we
want a million subscribers
dm can't my girlfriend come she she
can't
she can't oh oh she can't or she won't
yeah call back call earlier
all right mimi m is in the is in the is
in the stream lab
there's a couple of questions in this
chat i really want to answer super quick
let's do it
boys tomorrow tomorrow do you need misha
cons i watched the honest trailers
already by myself on my phone didn't
react to it
sorry but it was hilarious the lewis ck
joke
i loved
some writers from honest trailers reply
to me all about that
on twitter check that out and uh yeah
check out olivia's tick tock this is
great live streaming this is
great this is how greg really talked me
me
when mimi
when they use real life mental illness
disorder as a scary element in a villain
i uh example dissociative identity
disorder in split or
psycho spasmodic dysphonia in us
i love these movies but it's something
to think about or
the he she is the chosen one trope which
that got
so heavily played out recently
he she chosen trope is the disney's
biggest problem
whenever they really go wrong with their
characters becoming powerful
well and that became the theme of every
like reboot after a while is there
became this element of like you're the
chosen one somehow or like peter parker
your dad
had this destiny in mind for you and you
were april o'neil your dad
made these turtles and it's your destiny
it doesn't always need to be destiny you
know
it's like it's sillier a lot of the time
when it is um
what i think about this particular one
that you're pointing out though mimi
do you know what this is honestly this
is probably one of my top favorite live
streams you've ever done
it's like a great day this is a great
life
i really am enjoying this one a lot um
when uh good night chelsea thanks for
being here bud
um with the mental illness disorder i
think
there's proper ways to infuse that you
know
and sometimes it's not mental illness uh
sometimes it can be something
kind of like babadook where it's uh it's
it's about grief
but hereditary i think knows how to use
that really well
uh to really play like i said it's all
about if you know how to craft it into
the dna of your story
sometimes especially with mental illness
like when they go to a
hospital where people are mentally ill
like liking the halloween remake uh
or the soft reboot one and that one
they're used as like creepy yeah it's
like oh they're always creepy crazy
psychotic people
you know and that's not accurate that's
not true yeah and uh
and i think that's when it you can
easily easily so i actually i do
really agree with you that a lot of time
it's treated
very insensitively however i think
if your story can be about that with the
main character
done properly in a realistic way to
infuse it and it could be
more effective when it's not that
you know like i don't want to ruin
certain movies
but in split it's it is like he has the
id
he's got split personality and then one
of those personalities turned into a
super power
you know yeah that's that's like
we're stretching now yeah and we're yeah
and it's yeah
i think it is worth thinking about just
what are what are the
repercussions oh goodbye what are the
what are the repercussions of using
something that does affect real people's
lives and i
people love to balk at sensitivity but i
don't know like
movies are for everyone so you got to
think about these things and i think
another
thing to add on to the trope you pitched
is also when uh those movies where
uh uh uh um things like autism or
asperger's become like a superpower i
[ __ ] hate that
that flips out [ __ ] hate that like
the predator or like like an equalizer
type of thing where it's like yeah just
makes
this brilliant assassin or something
like that i i
uh well first off olivia or her job she
works directly with autistic children
it's her main job and they're all just
like taking it all
high quality targets
no it's i mean it's something that
especially for her is very
uh upsetting of how this has become like
like such a trope associated with people
with autism
and uh that is something that i yeah
especially it's not really a horror
movie trope it's more
like action or sci-fi movies or
thrillers
you know uh yeah that is uh because it's
used for
like a weird sense of empowerment rather
than being like a geek show
true that son yeah but thank you mimi
appreciate that it's a good one flev is
back in the left back
at it man if it wasn't clear what i mean
by transition all scenes are those two
three second pair
panoramic shots of city place between
scenes like
last trope i hate oh i get what you're
saying about the shots don't worry about
that
uh i hate creepy dolls [ __ ] them saw
chucky's bride at age
one zero ten
creepy dolls i i think i mean there's a
way to make it work
i think that transitional shots and
establishing shots
are are often very stock but sometimes
people do them in ways that are
invigorating
uh-huh yeah i mean creepy dolls you you
love marie hate him
i love tania or olson's comments in the
chat every time someone dies and when
they cry
every time someone dies and then they
cry
like jesus people grieving what's that
about
what bothers me more is when someone die
like this is an early part of
supernatural season six they introduced
these characters they're supposed to be
like
family and um and i've been loving this
latest season and someone uh mirna in
the chat asked earlier about if we're
gonna be doing more of those convention
bits
in october we will continue that um but
in supernatural the beginning of season
six they they have these like family
characters they'll just get killed off
they don't even like
have a mention about them like look
these guys are your family you guys
haven't seen me
bothered i was just another dead guy on
the team like who you know fodder
characters dad to the body count
when john talks about film it's great oh
i like a film
i saw a film last night uh nancy
my sweet nan last uh thank you nancy
last favorite uh john you read this
least least favorite
trope is third act breakups based on
misunderstandings that could be fixed
with two minutes worth of conversation
if the characters are that inept in
relationshiping after a whole movie
they're better off
single or with other people a thousand
percent
yeah you could you really couldn't have
said that any better
yeah there's so many that's why we
brought up the whole thing with someone
eavesdropping
and then making a decision to run the
[ __ ] away from the grouper town
i've got this one isolated piece of info
i need yeah
and i'm not gonna even investigate this
oh yeah that's absolutely true that's
good good call nancy i really appreciate
that
that seems like a fundamental scripting
thing is
yeah like having characters communicate
the way people do that
that's a tricky thing all right nancy
you're the last one on our stream last
day thank you very much closing the lab
out let's see what we
got let's load this one last time for
the super chats and we'll do a quick
round on everything on the regular chat
one last load
um yeah man
oh nancy nancy says i have bipolar 2
disorder and can brush it off now
but seeing it used as the motivation for
thriller horror bad guys was alienating
as a kid see like that especially in the
90s
oh 90s movies oh the bipolar just
they would often they would often
generalize
it too like bipolar and split
personality are not the same thing
at all yeah at all like and what we know
to be split personality
is is many things yeah you know like
it's only recently yeah that people have
started doing
more homework more homework
john how did you do this so smooth uh oh
yeah you pulled the little
uh yeah a little cursor there and and
just like
gently with your wrist just do your
magic there
uh oh okay so we got a few to get
through here and then we're gonna
wrap up with the die okay oh wow we're
way behind
all right okay we can do this we can do
this we got this guys
quality answers coming your way got a
niece or a gas station gas station
joking oh we missed that earlier with
the whole i dream of mine is to watch a
horror movie with you especially john
that's what that was at the gas station
was going off about
my bad driving again
thank you mds appreciate that having
someone yell watch out as a speeding
vehicle
approaches a character and someone
produces the speed to grab them
just in time oh yeah especially if
they're like walking out to the highway
or they're kind of trance and some
thought
grab my daughter pull them out of the
way yeah that's an annoying one yeah
that or always predictable too it's like
yeah just get looked at me a hit
yeah yeah it would surprise us i mean
that's that that and uh
and like semi trucks that make no noise
until they're right next to you and
they're
loud as [ __ ] and sound like monsters
oh yeah like in uh
um oh good night robbie brown good night
robbie thank you buddy
um so there was uh the another trope
going off of what you're talking about
mds and what you're mentioning
is the one where characters get hit by a
bus
like why are people always getting hit
by buses in these [ __ ] movies
people don't respect bus drivers they're
always like crossing
the street they're crossing the street
and sometimes a lot of times not even
like a chasing or something they're just
having an
argument like mean girls i thought did
it great because it was a reoccurring
bit
hit by a bus like that was funny but in
movies it just
happens so often i'm like who are these
bus drivers why does the bus driver
never get out of the bus to go check on
the person they hit
you you work for like the city come on
what the [ __ ] is going on in these
movies
uh hey i mean maybe we just don't live
in a
we we're in l.a our our public transport
is not that good maybe uh there are more
people getting mowed down by buses than
we realize verdugo
silver i think we know what movie he's
referencing john you got a better handle
on this script than i do
don't worry don't worry highlight
verdugo verdugs
escaping from something that moves final
destination yes thank you isaiah that's
a good one too
please john fordugo thank you verdugo
escaping from something that moves in a
straight line by running away
in a straight line i think we all know a
movie he's referring to
which became popular for that great
movie it's
one of my favorite sci-fi films of all
time the best review we've ever done
that we never put up on the channel and
re-shot the review
prometheus oh yeah the masterpiece
where they they bring up all these
questions that we're going to answer in
not alien covenant yeah
you really could running left or right
would have been an instrumental choice
for that yeah yeah
oh goodness this happened on a lot it
does happen
way too often it's like running away
from something that's like if you just
make a left
you'll be fine yeah and you feel like
you know just like one quick look like
you would
throw a look over your shoulder to see
what you're dealing with
even if you're freaked you know that's
true man a niece is back
when they are running away from
something in the woods and then they try
to hide behind a tree lol
like you couldn't find a better spot or
i guess if you're in the woods you could
try to bury yourselves under some leaves
or something like that
yeah you always hope that you would come
like in lord of the rings when they jump
off the path into just this like
particularly overgrown set of roots yeah
yeah it's like a natural hiding place
but
otherwise actually going off of what
you're talking about
what trope annoys me is if
like the the horror villain is like
right here like let's say like this is a
wall and john
is on the other side and i'm about to
peek over to see
john as he's cowering away and then
someone just calls my name or i hear
like something drop in the background
i'm like oh let me go the [ __ ] over
there
and not finish my glance over here
what was that oh well good thing no
one's here well
i'm gonna completely ignore this
situation now even though all i had to
do was
peek for a second hey man a little peek
and can end your life
all right why do i have the gorilla grip
where does that come from
because you got you're great with the
whap oh that's right
that's right that's still the greatest
reaction maddie back in the chat
maddie when the villain is shooting a
machine gun
kelly and the bullets somehow don't hit
the hero like is the villain that bad of
a shot
all of them yes all are all the henchmen
it's always most annoying
when they've established the villains
are a great shot until it's time to
shoot their lead
character who's like not far away i
can't you know when it's the big one
when it really counts i just can't
wait i'm nervous you know like what if i
don't have enough bullets
why do they turn into stormtroopers at
that very moment yeah
yeah i don't know everyone's got to go
back to gun school that's a great call
maddie
oh ramiro sanchez thank you romero
hi to you too thank you so much buddy
really appreciate that man just join the
chat
say hello hello right back to you love
you buddy thank you
uh christina thank you christina shout
out to my daughter
harley quinn real legal name for her
10th birthday happy birthday to your
daughter
really quick happy birthday harley i
just finished harley quinn season two
uh really liked it a lot love your work
i hope kite man comes back
talk to him um yeah that's a great name
to give your daughter
what i'm really hoping for for your
daughter's birthday if i'm hoping that
when she blew out her candles that she
wishes
that she her birthday wish was that she
does not turn into
a toxic codependent um
psychopath down the road
because that's harley quinn and i hope
you realize named
your daughter yeah yeah after actually
i'm just kidding she won't be that
she'll be way better than that she'll be
what dr
quinn should have been she'll be better
a good doctor she'll be better than dr
quinn or
harley quinn kevin smith happy birthday
to your daughter
robbie the shout out oh she might
especially don't ever see that part of
that joke right there
all right bane is hilarious in the
harley quinn show [ __ ] yeah
robbie brown when someone is the chosen
one oh yes oh yes
also just watch knives out for the
second time to look out for the clues
one of my faves of 2019. you know i i
need to see it again i've only seen it
the ones
knives out is a lot more what i wish
murder on the oregon express was yeah
that's a good call
oh yeah great call thank you robbie
appreciate that buddy
i'm glad that you agree with me that
your call was good yes
uh mark leach how's it going mark hey
mark marky mark
marky mark and the wahlburgers i want to
this super
i want to send the super chat to send
love to you both you make a difference
to us
and to anissa eric and bradley they have
helped make the discord family they
absolutely have
i want to see what you guys have
developed over at the discord is you've
developed real
personal relationships you guys have
really developed
friendships and within that sometimes
there can come
little like quarrels life things that
get brought up which i understand but
just keep in mind to keep communicating
with each other because
i've seen some other discords before
i've skimmed them and usually it all is
pretty much surface level discussion
and you guys have managed to find a way
to become very a very personal community
over there
and uh i really treasure it so i love
the hell out of you guys
thank you mark leach for saying that
because because of how close you guys
are
just know that sometimes it might might
require a little bit of extra
communication with you all
right but that's a big part of what
makes it special which a lot of discords
don't have so thank you guys so and
that's
your guys is doing yes you guys are
[ __ ] it's all you it's all yous thank
you mark for mentioning that big shout
outs to rosie beatty as well
especially rosie so much of that
administrative stuff
is is rosie good night maddie thanks for
being here for so long
anissa lisa i have to work tomorrow and
i don't want to go why the [ __ ] would
you
want to don't don't go just stop going
who needs to go
call in sick to work just go home
[Laughter]
do they just tell you to keep coming to
work today i'm sick well you should come
in because we weren't yours
we'll treat you and then we could just
get you right back we'll give you that
special oh yeah how do you call off work
if you work at hospital
there's no excuse pcp pop culture
podcast thanks dude jamie pull that [ __ ]
up
he's doing a joe rogan reference i get
it buddy did you get it
i did uh once you explained it yeah once
you said what it was i understood it
sounds like i have heard him say that
before on a joe rogan podcast
uh dragon soldier dragon soldier
how epic thank you for gracing us with
your presence
a horrible troop trope how about
super mario 2 syndrome where everything
turns out to be a dream in the end
it's a pretty letdown of a trope i feel
like it's been boiled down to the like
particularly shocking sequence that will
then be completely meaningless because
it was a dream
yes yeah it gets boiled down it's been a
while since i've seen a movie
end that way or it's like oh damn
there's got to be there's ways you can
do it again this is one of those tropes
that i feel like
can be a cop out or when the movie
seems like it it the main thing going
for it is that
by the time you get to that reveal
that's all you'll
really give a [ __ ] about is like oh my
god look at this twist look at the facts
but when you handle it like a like
jacob's ladder
i think does it very well we're like oh
wow that's what it was
but it's done in a way where the whole
thing is just a
strong character exploration to the
point where
the whole thing kind of feels ethereal
to begin with so it can be handled in a
way where i think it can work what i
don't like
is when the whole movie relies on you
being [ __ ] mind blown over this twist
and it hinges everything on it yeah yeah
it's like so clever for doing it
it's not real like the dream trope is
not done as much as the split
personality trope
like secret window or or uh or
fight club or you know yeah there's a
lot
more other movies to do uh but that i
think split personality trump has done
way more than dreamtrip but dreamtrip
definitely can be
pretty bad boogie anissa anisa i just
wanted to let y'all
know oh no i read the last one dude but
i read the last one of a niece's
boom i just want to let y'all know how
much i appreciate y'all and everything
you do for
us which you should so it's good that
you're saying this now
i know y'all are super busy and you
still take time out of your day to
respond so thank you we love you we love
you too we love you too
without you guys so much we wouldn't
have anyone to be here for
yeah we wouldn't have anyone to
entertain
but seriously yeah like thank you for
all the love that you guys show us and
all the energy
that you bring especially you and nisa
you've been a big part like
i know that rosie especially and i think
he has been nominated bradley to be
manager at the discord
um uh like with all i know that you've
been um
probably like the the way how like
captain america is the leader of the
avengers but really iron man's the star
it's kind of like what i view you as in
some way like you were the big
part of creating the person you and eric
horseman
big part of creating that real personal
interaction and camaraderie amongst
everyone
if if the world gets snapped away you'll
be one of the original avengers who has
solved the problem you know you'll get
to stay uh pcp pop culture podcast
what she said thanks oh thanks pcp
the master you're sweet dude xx master
thief xx who i see in the chat right now
has just asked the question i
don't really want to make sure i don't
miss this whatever happened to greg alba
always wondered it's not showing up here
um i am greg alba i don't know what
you're asking me exactly
i'm craig alba i thought you were ryan
right
well i thought you were jerry which was
a very different personality
jerry was way different from me let me
tell you jerry's been canceled
greg albert can be a little bit more
sincere when the moment calls for it and
doesn't need to make a dick joke all the
time
speaking of dick jokes click the dick to
subscribe
who is who is here for for that uh yeah
i don't know who was there for straight
to the point days
stan mccaffrey sent into soups
mccafferty sending a super chat and yet
there's nothing here what the hell stan
but appreciate it dude stan
appreciate it but it's okay because
chase's favorite trope is
our reactions oh which is a trope of
this
that's so sweet she's a trope of this
channel for sure anissa says my favorite
trope is y'all friendship
melts my heart that's a trope overdone
to death
well this friendship is melting my heart
too but not in a sentimental way it's
corroding
it's corroding there's like it's wanting
you guys
a real live version of the fly is slowly
taking place
and we are morphing into something else
behind the camera at any point we could
just be a writhing mass of gristle and
me
yes and bones i want to make sure this
is the last of them
the last speed round or some actual
questions thank you to everyone who's
contributed
a lot a couple more read off we gotta
honor them you gotta
honor the people robbie brown thank you
great stream
good night guys thank you buddy good
night robbie b good night sleep tight oh
i'm glad you asked this because i would
like to answer this in a very sincere
way hell yeah
um i box at night 23. thanks for being
back here in the stream he's asking how
you enjoy naruto bro
maybe you can react to it on patreon
once you get to ship it in if you want
i appreciate you having that caveat of
if you want honestly
um i have really been enjoying like
i'll give you an idea i'm on like
episode 73 right now
if i did that with patreon i'd be on
episode
five right now
and i've really been and more
importantly i've been really
reasons to see sergeant joy got it yeah
and and one of the things that i i've
been really
enjoying about my experience with naruto
is as honestly the
the private experience of watching this
with my girlfriend and
uh relishing in that and having just
this one-on-one
with her while watching the show because
she's seen the series before
but it's something that's so near near
her heart that she's always wanted to
show it to me and i've always been kind
of reluctant or hesitant or
but then watching that show with her has
been like a
just a joy being able to like talk
forever with her about it afterwards
uh i just love the binge experience with
her
on that so that one is going to be
personal but every once in a while i'll
give updates on what i'm thinking about
the show because yeah
it is undoubtedly one of the best animes
i've ever seen
boom it's [ __ ] great it is it is it
is seriously [ __ ] amazing
um it's it's one of the most hyped
animes ever
and pretty quickly started like okay
that's cool i'm getting i'm feeling it
but because you hear that the show has
like a gazillion episodes
that you kind of wait to like okay maybe
by like episode 200 is when it reaches
greatness right
you know it's one of it seems like it
might be one of those shows that like
it takes a long time before you finally
reach the great you gotta dedicate your
life to that but it was it wasn't too
it wasn't that long into it um around
the first main arc when they started up
the exams when i really started to go
like
when i started to tear up on the first
exam which all involved was naruto
trying to take a test
like an exit paper exam test um i i was
like i'm in love with this show
so yeah it's it is an incredible series
um
it's absolutely worth watching it's on
hulu
and that's when we answered that
question we answered it and i think we
just got one more in here i want to make
sure
no no honoring we gotta refresh this
page
you can uh i watch and sub sub
sub you can do as much digging on the
internet as you want but jerry had no
known last name
i don't know how many episodes are there
jerry wrong that's what it was
tm knows ryan wright and jerry wrong
uh thermonuclear thank you dude
s-i-e ben studios the game you see is
playing i'm planning on making a movie
from the game days gone with matt damon
and will smith no director of
screenwriter yet
that's not gonna pan out it's not gonna
pan out you know why
this is where it always [ __ ] goes
right please don't get your hopes too
high thermonuclear
that's how it always goes there's always
some early development
where they got like some giant ass
director or some
giant ass cast members and then it never
goes out and it goes like that
all almost every time it goes and then
it becomes notable because you just keep
hearing who leaves and who gets attached
yeah
it's it's so sometimes it pans out like
tom hall and mark wahlberg for uncharted
cool glad that happened but
most of the time like that that just
sounds
way too good to be true but if i'm wrong
hell yeah that sounds great yeah man
that sounds great thanks for pointing
that out to us bud hey man
mad matt matt do one last personal check
here matt damon
i it was weird i don't trust will
smith's judgment as well as i did
but uh yeah matt damon i do like that
asian movie he was in
uh and then nick a dog okay well check
buddy thank you dude
appreciate that man i'll ch i'll check
my messages thank you dude
all right guys thank you thank you so
much for being here
yeah seriously thanks for watching quick
questions in here
we're done with the super chestnut thank
you to everyone who contributed really
thank you this is a really fun i really
enjoyed this stream
yeah man this is a blasty blast it's
funny yeah because we were talking about
about being low energy today and it
turned into yeah such a fun time so
thank you guys as well it's one of those
things when you're feeling low energy
and out of it that i feel like when you
just explain it up front it starts to
relieve that fatigue and it's like okay
because you're like all right i don't
need to force anything because i'm
letting people know and then the natural
part of you starts coming
especially yeah performing too i think
there's a natural like oh i don't feel
like in the exact
you know like mood at the moment you
know
to be continued trope maybe we'll just
continue this another time because it
seems like an endless thing
paul from the philippines pinoy pride
buddy
oh look out look out love it youtube
bradley
ashu good to see you too buddy little
ass to be continued trope we will
continue this
eric horseman best movie soundtrack i
love that you're shouting out all the
love to all these people here my
favorite movie soundtrack i don't know
something with hans zimmer why the [ __ ]
nissan i love you we do gotta go
eric i gotta make some something else
for the boys it'll take a long time
tyler you're awesome thank you dude shoo
come on get your goodbyes in here
box at night hello see you buddy
oh goodness i love you too my friend
mirna this is fun this is fun
only a few people have said goodbye i
thought more people would say bye i know
bye erica oh bye erica matthew bruh
i'm still here by joaov as well we have
locked him in our remote security both
of you he wanted to get caught that's
what it is oh that's a trope
that's true it's getting caught part of
your plan
bye flav doran okay another name john
guys kubo rizzo gaming of course
roses all right guys and michael hagan
thanks for your super chat
hello hello to the uk michael o'hagan
all right patreon michael o'hagan by the
way shouts out to you you'll see your
name at some point this month
amen to that yes amen all right love you
guys
we'll see you all soon cheers john all
the love
close us out